What? I'm not the one who lost your >> No, I'm saying though
that when How many dramas, if you accept this logic, how many
more dramas can these people survive? How many more dramas can
William survive? How many more dramas can Nicholas Dioro survive
if that logic is accepted? How long is it until they are covering
someone who is also being spoken about in KF and they get doxed?
What is my level of responsibility here? How could I have made
the point I made about Willie Mack without being accused of dog
whistling to swat his wedding?
>> I really don't like you trying to go out of your way
to make this more complicated. I just wanted to see how reasonable
this is. There's a great reason for this because if >> Okay,
I was just really quick going to watch the Queenman monologue
from the start of his stream the other day. If you guys haven't
seen it, it's quite good. It It's a very like cogent defense,
like what his problems are with Willie Mack's video, why he thinks
it's garbage, right? It's very good. And I think he got an edit
for it. So, I'm going to check it out. I'm going to check it
out. I retweeted it earlier today. I didn't get a chance to watch
it last night, but I think we should actually watch it. So, real
quick, I'm going to throw this up just in case. Um, just in case
I don't know, some people are still around who are looking at
these things. Queen full screen. So, look at himself during the
monologue. You think he's reading from a script when he looks
down, but he's actually just got a little locket with his own
picture in it twice. Both sides of the locket. He's like holding
it in his hand for good luck. He's got a picture of himself and
a and himself in a heart-shaped locket. Okay. It's just two pictures
of him. So, you think he looks down at a script? He doesn't look
down at a script. I promise. >> No. Willie Mac released
a video last night. It's a video mainly about Bad Empanada and
Bad Empanada doxing Willie Mac's wedding. Now Willie claims bad
empanada is not the one who doxed his wedding. I take a slightly
different definition of doxing. Now that is what bad empanada
did. 100% that is what he did. Now did he originate the dogs?
No. The dox originates with
a Kiwi Farms post by a completely anonymous account as far as
I can see that has two posts, neither of which mention me. I
don't know how I'm supposed to have any control over that. I
don't know how I'm supposed to take any responsibility for that,
but there's nothing I can do about this, despite what Willie
Mack probably wants you to believe. Willie Mac's basis ascribing
this to me now, a clip that takes place weeks after Willie has
already been doxed. He
uses that to claim that I am the one doxing him or that my fans
are the ones doxing him. Does originating the docks really matter
that much? Not in Queman's opinion. Well, sorry. Yeah, not in
Queenman's opinion. Usually originating the docs cannot be differentiated.
Oh man, never mind. Hold on. Hold on. Here's the problem. A doc
is only a docs is if you take private information, information
not known online or even just not even not. If you take private
personal information, stuff that can be used to track somebody
down or uniquely identify them and you publish that with the
intent of harassment. Okay? Take PII and publish it for the purpose
of harassment. Now, if you originate a dox, you basically are
always doing that. There's very few cases where you could originate
a dox, accidentally dox somebody, right? And it really is truly
just a mistake. Spreading or making that dock shouldn't matter
morally.
Um, I think, wait, why not? That's a that's a weird argument,
Stalin Sloth, I don't know how where you're coming from with
this. So, the person who's originating the docs did so for the
purpose of harassment. That's doxing, right? Quan accidentally
had it play on his stream. He did not have the intent to harass
Willie Mack with that docs, right? That was not the intent. That
is not the same thing, right? Accidentally letting a video play
from a quote tweet from Destiny where he's like criticizing it
and it's playing muted in the background and he doesn't see that
the censoring fails at one point. That's not the same as like
anybody else who's involved here, right? Who would actually be
trying to harass Willie Mac? But Stalin Sloth, if you can continue
that thought, I'd be interested to know what you mean here cuz
I actually don't know. Anyway, we'll continue. And that necessarily
has to be the case because in the clip William's talking about,
I'm reacting to a Destiny quote tweet of Gate Fumodor. And this
Gate Fumodor person posted a video, a clip of Bad Empad's video
of uh of Willie Max.
Now, in Willy's own video,
Willie says he does not blame Destiny because by the time Destiny
quote tweets his docks, it's already viral.
It's already broadly seen. So, I am absolutely
baffled how I am supposed to have any responsibility
when the quote tweet I am covering to make my point about Destiny
already has like a 100,000 200,000 views when I'm looking at
it and I have a few hundred live and then I censor it for the
the Vault upload because obviously I don't intend to do Willy
M. So, a few hundred people saw this through my stream when hundreds
of thousands have already seen it through Destiny's video. Yet,
Willie Mack uses that logic to absolve himself
of any culpability in Jstalks because Destiny or Destiny's fans
had already posted it with hundreds of thousands of views. But
for some reason, this logic that Willie Mack uses to absolve
himself
doesn't apply to me. That's not the >> of course that logic
is completely,
right? I didn't valine.
Um, but the whole point is is if you were if you're doing something
to harass someone, you're trying to post, right?
Um, you're trying to post, it shouldn't matter if you're getting
like 50 views or a,000 views, doing something immoral is still
bad. Yeah. Like I actually totally disagree with Stalin sloth
here, right? Like I think I think the fact that you're like participating
in doxing, that you're trying to help somebody get harassed,
right? I think that's crazy. U I I think the idea that you don't
matter, that you can like participate in harassment, it doesn't
really matter. That you can like participate in more views going
to that thing that's literally only been published with the uh
with the purpose of harassing somebody. It's like, dude, what
are we talking about? Isn't that what he's saying? Well, Queen's
saying it's it's dumb. That's not what Willy's saying. Willy's
saying the opposite. That like scale matters the most. Lily saying
what Stalin sloth is saying which is depending on how many people
make you see it right depending on how people make you see it
or sorry depending on how many people see it the scale of it
that's what determines whether or not it's like bad or how bad
it is and it's like it's still bad action on that person's part
like that person still I don't know it seems like that person
still right oh morally the same okay all right oh sorry okay
then never mind okay Jesus you you started the argument like
in a very strange way I guess I wasn't following at some point
where you said cuz you talked about the scale.
Second one is just as culpable as the first. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sure.
Oh, I the way you said that like a 10 viewer Andy. I I didn't
read the whole thing. That's my bad. Anyway, we continue. So,
I didn't read your whole message. You started with like 10 viewer
Andy and then like a big influencer. I was just like, "Oh, he's
arguing that like scale." But I I didn't actually read through
it. So, that's my bad. I didn't read through your whole message.
where Willie Mack is
refusing to apply vindicating logic that he knows to be true,
that he knows himself to believe, where he refuses to apply it
for me, but is happy to apply it for himself or for his friends.
So, great example of this, the Dark Viper drama. Chud was obviously
going back and forth with Dark Viper pretty hard over a copyright
strike. Kiwi Farms latched onto it. Kiwi Farms ended up doxing
Dark Viper. Dark Viper made these massive claims of people etching
stuff into his door, scratching stuff into his door. And what
did Willie Max say? What did Willie Max say? He said, "You can't
ascribe that to child logic community with no evidence." >> You're
prescribing a doxing allegation to his community based on nothing.
It's
>> You need edit goes hard. I love the edit. Let's go.
>> To show some evidence to start ascribing that to child's
community. You can't just smear him with the insane behavior
of some Kiwi farmers who happen to have latched onto this drama.
And it's not like he's just said that once either. Uh, is this
website zero and Kiwi Farms? Oh, it's crazy that Keeles decided
that website zero was was actually not to blame at all. It was
all going to go on Kiwi Farms. Yeah, I'm sure we've got multiple
places where Willie said this. >> In the Keeles drama,
Willie makes the same points. He says it's insane for Keeles
to ascribe the actions of website zero who yeah we won't say
the name here for all the many reasons people said before website
zero describing their actions to Kiwi Farms simply because KE's
Kiwi Farms page was so active at the time ascribing the swatting
or the doxing to Kiwi Farms even though the doc was reposted
on there describing the doxing and the swatting to Kiwi Farms
is absurd. Website zero is what Keeles portrays Kiwi Farms as.
Kiwi Farms is a glorified gossip forum where people troll and
use slurs. People do box docks on it, but it's not what the site
is for saying other.
>> Dude, how did he put that video out? How did Can you
just Can anybody explain to me how in the world this [__]
decided, oh, you know, would be a good idea be to put a video
out like actually accusing these people of doxing me with no
evidence whatsoever. Website zero is a website where actual it's
called Doc Bin. This is a different site. People didn't want
to talk about it back then. I don't know if it super matters
now. It's just dox bid. That was the site. Anyway, dude, he has
got multiple videos excoriating people for doing this exact thing
that he is doing now. And somehow he thought like this is why
you can actually this is the best piece of evidence to point
to to say whatever Destiny says that's this guy's entire critical
thinking process. Right. Well, Destiny thought that uh the couple
bad for lying about Kumi Farms. And now Destiny thought we could
lie about Kumi Farms. So I liable kiwi farm facy. Yeah, that's
Willie Matt's entire thought process. That's the only thing that
goes on in there. Okay. And there's two and then there's two
playing like ping pong in a corner. There's just nothing. There's
nothing going on there. >> Wise is like getting doxed on
Twitter and then saying all of Twitter is a doxing site. Website
zero is a malicious group of hackers and doxers meant to harass
their target. Not just online, but in real life as well. Saying
in her DMs with Destiny, "I was scared website zero users aren't
stupid like Kiwi Farms users. So this whole campaign is built
off of a lie. Website zero was too scary to go after. So she
made it about the infamous troll site. Like what is 4chan
>> Because just because there's a bunch of activity there
doesn't mean it's them. And they moderate against it. They moderate
against it much like I do. Much like I always do. I even moderate
against doxing. So like it's key farms level. He would obviously
make those points back then. He has in his careful videos. He
covered keles himself. He wouldn't consider himself part of the
harassment against Keles. That would be
Yet in this video, he is perfectly happy to take a bunch of unsubstantiated
harassment claims. Claims from not soite that my community or
J community has swatted her trying to get her deported. I hear
being claimed taking this absurd claim from the schizophrenic
Odashara on Twitter that J community sent a letter to him, something
that he's been asked for evidence for before.
guys. Uh they I got banned from the Discord and uh for calling
people furs in the VCs and I call people furs cuz they they said
that you know I'm a waiting. I hated that and now I got a letter
to my house a couple days later and they called me a waiting
in the letter. This community is unhinged. Oh, could you show
us the letter? No, I threw it out. Oh, could you like maybe keep
future evidence? Oh, yeah. Okay. I'm pretty sure it wasn't you
guys though. 98% sure. Don't ask me for anything else in the
future. Okay. Okay, >> To provide >> sure to throw
away the letter or some >> but he's perfectly happy just
to repeat these with with little to no interrogation as to the
the truth of the claims. Anyone with any [__] sense
who's left in the the pockets of commentary community or whatever
that means at this point has immediately clocked
that this is an utter breach of standards, a complete abandonment
of the very logic that has allowed their careers to flourish
for 10 years, 5, 10 years.
the exact delineation of responsibility drawing clear lines where
when you moderate your community to keep a behavior out. You
can't be blamed for if some anonymous schizophrenic who latches
on to the stuff you're saying goes and does something in a place
where you have no control. This is by the way not just commentary
but also the Destiny community, right? This was the entire thing
where Keeles was taking so like basically what she was saying,
she's saying this has happened consistently. She'd take like
instances of actual harassment and she'd say, "This Destiny's
community, they're doing they're crazy. They're out of their
minds. They need to be banned everywhere, right?" And the response
was, "Yeah, obviously we can't control like one or two people
going off and saying something insane, right? But if you give
us their names, you give us like any info you have on them, we
can ban them across everything. Like we'll do our best to keep
we don't want people like that in our community. Just give us
the evidence, right? And we'll ban them." That was the actual
That was the exact line that Destiny and his mods took. That
that's the exact line that Quimman, I
uh Auggie, all of the people around us would have, right? That
is the only acceptable line.
It's the internet. We don't have shackles around these people.
We can't track these people. We don't know where they are. We
don't know where they've been, right?
How in the are we supposed to control what they do? Like one
person who gets amped up and says, "Oh, this person's like like
they go and use the the TLE or something with Keflles." It's
like I can't [__] control that. That doesn't mean
my community is transphobic. That means a transphobe. watched
my content and got really mad that you're like trying to deplatform
me,
right? That's all it means.
And by the way, that's in the case where it could actually be
ascri where it could actually be traced back to a user who's
active in your community. We haven't even hit that spot yet,
right? They haven't shown that somebody did this that docs somebody
docks one of these people who's an active participant in our
communities at all.
Or if if they if they have evidence of that, they haven't shown
it to us. So there's no way for us to moderate it. There's nothing
for us to do. So they just make this accusation with no proof
whatsoever and they want all of the benefits which includes trying
to doxman and trying to dox me. They want all of those benefits.
We get to dox you with impunity and we don't have to show any
proof of the fact that you are doxing us or working anywhere
near close to the people who tried to dox us. How is that a sane
world to live in? They don't know why you spicy chat. Dude, it's
crazy. They need that logic to stand there. How many dramas if
you accept this logic? How many more dramas can these people
survive? How many more dramas can William Mac survive? How many
more dramas can Nicholas Dioro survive if that logic is accepted?
How long is it until they are covering someone who is also being
spoke about in KF and they get doxed? What is my level of responsibility
here? How could I have made the point I made about Willie Mac
without being accused of dog whistling to swat his wedding? How
could I have what is a way I could have phrased that point that
Destiny's standards leave his own supporters and fans open to
being doxed and harassed? Harassed. How could I have phrased
that to where Willie Mack could not have accused me of dog whistling
in the way he did? There is not a single way. >> I think
I remember I I think I watched this live. Okay. I think there's
one more misspeak that we're going to forgive and then >> I
could have phrased that where he wouldn't be able to make that
same allegation
especially when in the clip and you might not realize this when
you watch the video through a first time cuz he chops up the
clips and leaves pots you know it gives a 5minute gap between
stuff I explicitly state that I'm not okay with doxing that I
don't believe it's no bad tactics only bad targets that's in
fact been a key point that I have been hammering for 5 months
at this
For a long time, this has been a key point that anyone who has
been even in like osmosis range of my community knows I have
been hammering about Destiny, about Ethan, about all these commentary
guys. There's not a wink and a nudge. There's not a, "Oh, no,
but actually we do." No, I don't. Unequivocally,
obviously, like anyone that has watched any of my content would
know. >> Just right there. Okay, that's You see the eyes
go there? He's looking at pictures of himself right there. Okay,
he's giving himself
the the confidence he needs to keep going. He's good. Nods. You
see the You saw the little nod, right? The little nod. Sees it.
Quick little nod to himself. Quick little nod to himself. >> So,
what am I to do? >> I got this. >> Oh, yeah. So,
two other things. So Willie claims that it was my audience that
doxed him initially, but I had no knowledge, nor did anyone in
my community, from what I know, have knowledge of Willy's wife
being Israeli or now that was actually public. That's not even
Doc's information to say Willy's wife or girlfriend or whatever
Israeli is Israeli or He actually does have old tweets
talking about how his wife's Israeli. There's old clips of him
talking about his how his girlfriend's Israeli. He has said that
on his streams. That's not even that wouldn't even be doc's information
to spread that. But I had no idea until the bad empanada docs
was viral. So the idea that I had any idea Willy Mac's wife was
was Israeli
is absurd. The idea that my community were doing it. I I literally
hadn't even seen the post on KF cuz I don't read that thread
every day. I just check in when there's like some big leak I
have to grab info for. You know, it's like if there is some big
story developing, yeah, people go to KF like commentary YouTubers
do like all commentary like Turkey Tom, like Willie Mac, like
Nick Dioro, like any of these people would >> when a big
story
>> develops, they go and visit because that is where they
compile, that's the word I'm looking for, compile archives of
>> which there's nothing wrong with if you just want to
go get clips from like Kiwi Farms or somewhere where somebody
would watch and they would actually archive a stream so that
if it gets deleted, you can go find the backup version. There
is nothing wrong with that. Yes, genetic fallacy every time.
Oh, look at look at this watermark. That watermark means this
isn't a real clip. No, it doesn't. Also, another Keell's argument,
by the way. Also another Keell's argument. So, if someone in
a big situation is taking stuff down, leaking stuff,
it's going to be posted there. It's going to be posted there.
And they've defended that and they've defended the use of it.
Destiny has defended the use of it. That was the whole KEF's
arc. That was the whole thing was you can't just use ancillary
connections to KF to ascribe all the responsibility for KF's
actions to those content creators and then use KF's
uh ancillary
nature to potential swatters to blame KF for all swatting. You
can't just draw these connections of responsibility to try and
rope everyone in and shut down criticism, which is what they're
doing. Make no mistake. >> Make no mistake. Yes. It's that's
the only thing it is, right? That's the only thing they care
about. Hey, you're calling me like a Destiny sweeper.
Did you know that that gets me doxed? Do you know that when you
call out my like light touch with Destiny, my coordinating with
people in Destiny's life as business partners and stuff for information
for my videos, when you point these things out, right? We point
things like this out. My continued like participation in that
sphere that actually gets me doxed. That actually gets me [__]
with. How did I bump down to a one month sub? I have no idea,
dude. No idea. So, you have to stop saying it. You have to stop
saying I like Destiny. Stop saying that. It's like, bro, ain't
nobody doxing you for liking Destiny, for like being ancillary
to Destiny's community or even somebody we criticize. That's
not happening. There's nobody who's going to do that. Who's going
to go, "Oh, you know what? Queen said this guy's an orbiter.
I'm gonna go dox this guy. There's that. That's never happened.
Okay. They're not gonna like go and try to like find information
on this person for that reason. Again, the thing that happened
with Hutch was not, hey, Quimman just said this guy's a Desty
sweeper, so I'm going to go dox him, right? So, I'm going to
go find out all this information on him. It was like literally
somebody saw a clip. It was like, oh, is the sky been doxed?
And somebody posted what what had already existed in the thread
for months. Now, that's still an instance of doxing. that is
reposting the information for the purpose of like technically
harassing that person.
But it's not like somebody went to all of this effort. It's not
like somebody who's like you have unhinched schizophrenics who
are going to go and find all of these people. It's like I'm sorry
that you didn't know. You'd kind of already been doxed. You'd
think maybe somebody who's following that thread would have given
you a quick update would have said like hey just say no. This
happened just say no.
Apparently not. >> That is what Willy's doing. He has been
fighting with us for months.
for months and only now attempts to even remotely engage with
anything anyone said in one of his videos because why? Because
he found an opportunity to shut shut down criticism obviously.
On top of that, one of Destiny's dogs attempts on me is in both
of his videos. A name is in both of his videos. And in his second
video, he plays a portion of the released cherry audio, the non-consensual
cherry audio
portion, and shows all the KF posts of where to find it. So,
the idea that I am >> total [__] psychopath
>> for leaving a video playing on autoplay
that Destiny has already quote tweeted to 200,000 people. The
idea that I am getting blamed for that live when I censored it
in the upload got throwaway to censor it on Twitter even though
I usually don't control the people that [__] clip
my [__] at all. I know I don't like making recommendations
to them or anything like that. Willie
had to be basically pressured into fixing the Cherry stuff. It's
like totally absurd.
Willie does not care about this doxing >> Uh I got in a
Hold on. I got in a long group chat.
Hold on. I can't see this message. Ew. Hold on. I got a long
group chat debate with people who are convinced that you have
spread Destiny's docs and think you are looking at his KF thread
on stream is like and think you looking at his KF thread on stream
is like terrible behavior. They're kind of rabid about th the
idea you're fostering a hate community that doxes those close
to Destiny. You and Quimman I should say. Um Izzy Mandas
evidence.
When have I pulled up KF on stream? I'm not saying I haven't.
I may have, but I'm usually pretty careful about not actually
showing like providence of most things.
I've gotten a little less careful now with everything going on.
Like like sorry when I say like I feel like it's incumbent on
me when when I'm getting blamed, you know, for being for being
complicit in Hutch getting like redoxed or something. I feel
like it's a it's incumbent on me to say, "Hey, just so you know,
you're the person who found your information was like weeks or
months ago, right?" No, no, no, no. Izzy Mandas isn't saying
this. He's saying that no, no, no, no, no, no. I I totally understand
what Izzy Mandas is saying. I'm saying that for those people,
how you would respond to that is saying like, "Show the evidence.
Show me like showing his docs somewhere. Show me spreading his
docks. Show me doing any of that." I think KF links are are banned
in the Discord, right? There might be some
um it's it's possible. Hold on. Let me see here. I think I think
it's like literally in the auto filter out or something. See
here. The only the only
KF links I see is one link that was to Shadman's thread and then
there's one deleted user post in a
for a KEF's thread, but other than that, there aren't any publicly
visible KF threads or KF links on the Discord from what I can
see. So,
yeah, I'm looking right now. That's what I said, but they weren't
having it. I asked for explicit proof of you doing anything like
that, and they insisted you fostering a hate community leads
to that kind of harassment. Where's the hate community? Like,
I'm sorry, but like Destiny is a topic in the Discord, but it's
because he violated people who were already members of this community.
That's why he's a topic in the Discord, right? So, I'm not, by
the way, I'm I'm speaking like a little forcefully. Obviously,
I'm not mad at you, but like, how do we how do we even defend
ourselves against this? How do we even They won't They won't
They don't need proof. They could just say it, right? Like, I
can show you all of the Dude, uh, it's crazy. Um, what did Destiny
Destiny posted like um a Google doc from the stream and people
went and like spammed uh spammed like doc in there um like a
former I guess like stream schedule or stream like dock it. He
posted that in his group chat. He's like explicitly trying to
do like Kiwi Farms on me and Cherry and Quean and a bunch of
other people, right? He is using his community for that. Oh yeah,
he is also here in stream chat, right? Like he is actually explicitly
doing all of the things that they claim are really bad. He is
explicitly doing them, explicitly encouraging that all the time.
So I just I don't get it. Like at what point I understand at
this point that like none of these people had any actual principles
on this. Like I get it. But honestly any of those people could
come on stream and make like an argument, right? But their arguments
are all going to go the same way because they're losers and they
they are just in a cult, right? They're all going to be the same
thing where it's like, well, but wouldn't you say that like if
you talk a lot about this guy that like people might get like
they might feel really bad about him and then maybe they could
go to like KF and then maybe they could like participate and
then maybe eventually they could like see that docs and then
maybe they could give it to other people and then like maybe
there'd be like 50 well maybe they could also do this things
right yeah but I don't do that Izzy Mandius I literally don't
do that right and so how do these people believe this I would
just ask like how do they No. Like why? Like I would explicitly
say like unless you can show me some evidence of this, you appear
to be in a cult. Like you are just in a cult until you show me
evidence. You have a cult-like belief in this with nothing you
can show. Why don't you just compile him being a hypocrite into
one pick to post on X every time he makes the claim? Um I mean
he also says he's explicitly like a hypocrite. He also explicitly
says I just dox people now.
Uh he's been in here a couple times. full of al calling them
a cult has no effect on them because they're in a cult. Yeah,
you kind of have to h Man, there's a lot of different tactics.
I just wish I wish these people would keep coming on stream.
That's the That's the funny thing is he's made the community
seem so dangerous or scary that people won't come around. Like
the DJers don't come around as much. And I like when they come
around because like anybody who makes these claims looks immediately.
Like if they try to make these claims on the stream, they look
every single time, but they've like all run away to like various
different places and they they know that they can't actually
do anything. They literally think that because your community
hates him, that's enough reason to suspect that you and Queen
spread his docks and look at a KF on his stream. It's impossible
to argue with.
Okay, I just did. They watch any of the Keell stuff? Just ask
them to go read the Keles manifesto because it's literally all
of the defenses against this stuff are all in there. Anyway,
anyway, we could we could continue on with Queenman here. >> Had
to be basically pressured into fixing the cherry stuff. It's
like totally absurd.
Willie does not care about this doxing incident. Okay, this is
pretense. purely pretense because it's a safe way to swing at
me, to swing at Jason, to swing at Ogie because we put pressure
back because there has been he's hit a brh.
>> What the is what the is my diaper fetish that people
keep talking about? Who's talking about it, Destiny?
Wait, is he watching like the VOD or something? Central CDT.
Is that not like is that 3 minutes ago? That's not 3 minutes
ago, is it? That's not That's There's no way. That's like two
or three minutes ago and he's like watching again. There's no
way. There's no way. There's just There's simply no possible
way that that's what's happening right
>> Yo, Gucci Jesus, thank the three months. Let's go. I
That's crazy. That's crazy.
I Okay, >> he's pressure and he wants to take a swing.
And I'm pretty cal. >> The funny thing is is like I dislike
Destiny and I I feel like physically ill. Like I kind of wanted
to watch the Brad Taste interview. I don't know what happened
there. I kind of want to watch Brad Taste talk to this guy cuz
like realistically some of the people who made fun of Brad Taste
the most over the Ethan Ethan Klein stuff was us like the DG
community. We ragged on this guy so hard, right? I'm pretty sure
Destiny retweeted that that quote tweet of it. the quote tweet
of like my the comic that people made, right? We were like, we're
doing a stream. We're like, we should do the bike meme with like
his grandma dying and we we posted it and then I'm pretty sure
Destiny retweeted it and now he's talking to Brad.
Oh, but anyway, suffice to say, uh I wanted to watch that, but
listening to that dude's voice makes me physically ill. I don't
understand how he could if he really hates me. I don't understand
how he could watch this stream so much cuz it makes me physically
ill to to hear that person's voice. I I don't get >> confident
even more so than I would be from just the previously public
information that this is the case because just now just within
the last hour or two or appeared on Chud's stream when Willie
started talking about sort of how he was feeling. Orgie tried
to sort of push back and ask a couple questions be like, "Oh,
what are they doing? They're harassing you. What's what are they
doing? They're harassing you. What?" Oh. Uh, Auggie went on to
Chudlo Logic's stream to speak about how Willie not only misprayed
their conversation about Salvo, that he was actually speaking
about this to empathize with Willie while he vented about the
harassment and doxing by Queen and Jtock.
I love that. I love that Auggie felt like he was like, "Man,
it must be like he really hates Queenman, but he really hates
Jtock, too." Like, he actually couldn't tell who Lily had complained
more about privately.
He's like, "Ah,
these guys apparently really hates both of them." Orgie tried
to sort of push back and ask a couple questions, be like, "Oh,
what are they doing? They're harassing you. What's what's happening?"
And Willie freaked out. Willie freaked out. Willie instantly
apparently goes to Orgie. Are you recording me right now? You
trying to set me up? Because he fears
that I or or Chud or someone is in everyone's ear trying to turn
people against this guy. And that that's why all of a sudden
people are talking about him. Why all of a sudden people are
saying, "Wait, is this guy?" Not because of his own embarrassing
actions.
Not because for a long time his videos have been swept for despite
being utter dog being essentially clip compilations that fail
to make any argument through the entire runtime in some of them.
Not because he has no understanding of the principles he espouses
and simply adopts them because they're convenient from the groups
that he's in, but because I must have, and this is a Destiny
narrative, too. I must have me a sub 10k hard stuck sub 10k
500 viewer max. Hold on. Hold on. Is that still true? Did he
not did he not bump up at all from the all the stuff on Twitter?
There's no way. He's got to have made 10K now. Especially with
that shout out like that. 9.85K.
Getting close. Getting close. Get there.
Get there. Get there. Get there.
streamer control the entirety of H3 Snark Kiwi Farms commentary
YouTube the Destiny community cast dude why
I don't want this weirdo watching my stuff go away go away weirdo
go away go away
get the out of here doesn't even know the he's brought up on
his own stream that like this was a thing he showed to be like
look how unhinged these people are by the Hey,
just going to point out again, you don't have to go after anybody
else. You don't have to go after anybody else. I'm just going
to say I'm I'm just going to say the people who started that
one, the cat backpack thing, that's those people are not here
anymore, okay? And not because they were unhinged. Those were
the best parts of those people, okay? Not cuz they're unhinged
towards Destiny, cuz they don't like parts of the community on
a personal level. Okay? Was the what even is the cat backpack
meme? Well, I don't want to tell him. I would like for him to
go look it up, right? I don't want to have to tell. If I tell
him, then he's going to know. Don't say it in chat. Don't say
anything. Don't say anything. Don't say anything. Okay, let him
go figure it out on his own. Let him go figure it out on his
own.
Offs
Hassan Per and his entire community. I somehow am the epicenter,
the divergence point for these communities where everything comes
together. The person pulling everything together. I'm hearing
Destiny compare me to her apparently on stream today. Something
that is beyond parody. Hysteria that is beyond parody. And for
what? Because I was just the first guy saying,
"Hey,
maybe people are going a little bit too far and excusing actions
against people that are against their own principles."
And now apparently I'm the guy who's no bad tactics, only bad
targets. After months of fighting on that, after hemorrhaging
viewers,
for
3 to 6 months over that exact position, over arguing that dude,
it would have been so easy to just slide into that like the pro-H3
stuff. It would have been so easy to slide into that lane, make
a money, right? Just make a money off of that. I had a huge schism
in my audience over like being like, "No, I think the Hassan
stuff went too far." Massive schism. Led people off. Doesn't
matter. Doesn't matter. Sometimes you just got to say what's
right, what's >> Exact position
for people that I don't have any sympathy for. Particularly Hassan
Per, Bad Empanada,
whoever it is, they've decided to sign a Denims TV. Like I give
a about denims.
But somehow
somehow they have found a way to just manufacture this desperate
smear when I have for months laid out exactly what my criticisms
are. Think for all these people who claim Willie who says this
all the time. If you've got an issue with my video, if you've
got an issue with something I said, respond to it. Fire up a
live stream and react. Do a response video. Why is it that we're
the only engagers? Ask yourself, why is it that where he only
engages with a single clip where he can cry victim in a completely
incoherent way with the rest of the arguments in the video about
doxing and his wedding and his bride? Why is it that that is
the only thing Willie engages with? I think the answer's pretty
obvious. I think the answer's pretty clear.
from mainstream appearances to dunk on previous partners on Twitter
at the tender age of 36. I think he's 37, isn't he? Oh, no. 37
in four months. Got it. I just wish, dude, nothing. It's whatever.
If he wants to sit here and if he wants to sit here and spend
his time doing this, it is what it is. Anyway, that was the that
was the monologue, the opening monologue here. But we got nothing.
We got no we got no response as far as I know. Okay. Where's
our Willie
Willie said anything today? really he talking about his video
at all? He just retweets some other people.
Come on, man. Is he really not He's really not out here saying
anything? No, he's not.
Imagine releasing a video and then a bunch of people have criticism
and you kind of just like dip out of social media. I don't Here's
the problem. I don't think that you get to release this video
and then dip out. You could dip out. You could block all these
people. You could start ignoring them, right? You could do that.
But if you want to release a video and make like totally baseless
accusations right after that, uh, you then you
you Okay. Anyway, where are we? Where are we going now? Okay,
we have a couple different options. We can finish the Ian Carol
thing. I kind of want to finish the Ian Carol thing. Oh, maybe
not. No, no, no, no, no. Never mind.
It's just a lot of Israel posting. He talks about the Tucker
Carlson CIA stuff, but we've gone through that already. Hutch
convo went. I'm not touch I'm not talking to Hutch on stream.
I I would talk try to talk to him off stream. I'm not going to
talk to him on stream. I don't think there's any point in trying
to talk to Hutch on stream if you're talking about me. Um he
thinks the temperature is too high. He would there's no way we
could have trust in that conversation, right? There's just no
no way that that would be possible. Yeah. So anyway, Kelly logs
were addressed earlier in the stream. Shut it down. I'm probably
not doing the Brad Taste interview. I guess we're if we're done
with that, we're probably gonna watch what another
20 minutes of this or so and then and then we will see. Thought
he detached himself entirely from DG. Uh maybe. I don't know.
Listen
>> You think your little games playing around?
That's interesting. Oh, we're going to impugn his motivations.
You think that's going to stop me? Really? Nothing stops a generational
run.
You know what my name is? Look up what my name means. I'm the
people's champion from birth.
That's on groer. Anyway, >> oh that is not No. Why did
you say that's on groer? You can't That's a super unforced error
right there. That's a super unforced error. Did you see Denims
was watching Hila Klein's red bar exercise video? No shot. Smash
the foul button. Smash the like button. Leave a comment. Let
me know what you think about the show. Check out the Sam Hyde
collaboration finally dropped over the weekend. Talk about wholesome.
That's a real as well. Love that man. Sam Hyde.
>> My biggest inspirations. Yay. Sam Hyde. Donald Trump.
>> It stings a little. >> Alex Jones. It does a little.
>> These are real. But the Sam Hyde interview dropped.
Everybody's loving it, you know, and people are talking about
the fit. I was wearing this like leather jacket. His idea. >> Someone
was bringing up. >> So, credit where it's due. >> Okay.
I'll I'll maybe check that out. Just get in some water real quick.
Did we watch Nick Sam Hide yet? We watched a little bit of it
at the beginning. It was uh
but it you know people are talking about the fit. I was wearing
this like leather jacket his idea. >> Give me two seconds.
>> So credit where it's due. But I hope he check it out.
It's on YouTube. I reposted I think it's just like a trailer
for it on Twitter. Uh but everybody was loving it and it was
really great to sit down with him. I haven't done any collaboration
with Sam in like 5 years since January 2020. That's when we did
the Q video. the Ronald McDonald. So, it was um it was kind of
a special thing because in many ways we both did we've both been
through a lot of the same stuff. We both were based and really
on the same page back in 2017 and then we both got cancelled
for our politics and I know we both grappled with this like trying
to survive under censorship and pressure to conform and things
like that. So, it was like a real recognized, real moment.
And the whole crew is great there. I met the whole crew. Those
guys are all phenomenal. All really funny. Ryan I've known a
long time. He is just one of the finest people ever.
I mean, seriously, Ryan Rivera, who used to work with Gavin,
now works with Sam, I've known him for, I don't know, seven years,
and that is one of the realest guys out there. Real homie. But
they're all they're all phenomenal.
Um, so anyway, so go ahead and check that out. That's on YouTube.
And I guess we'll dive into the show. So now look. >> Okay,
I'm back. Is Nick dating a black woman? Why is he talking like
this? Uh, he just listen. He just cooks the way he sees fit.
Okay
dive into some of the information tonight. We're going to unpack
all the allegations.
>> All right, we got we got that segment finished. All
right, where are we going to go next? It might be time for the
Nick stuff. Honestly, that could be that could just be the case.
Might be time for the Nick Wickly. Okay,
let's check it out. Hold on. What are we What are we doing in
the Discord today? Okay. Okay. Okay. I'm going to go look for
this Nick stuff. Okay. Where he uh fires his driver. I think
I had a YouTube video. That was just it. Me find it. Let me find
it. Apparently, this
>> apparently this is the start of their
>> Crash out. Scavenger hunt. Kate's Diamond. Oh, there's
a
I'm not going to cry anymore.
I'm walk.
So, I'll just point out that like she clearly she's clearly just
vibing, right? With her eyes closed, just
>> Bang, bang, bang. >> Bang, bang, bang.
>> You're not going to scare me.
>> This feels like a a dick move, Jacob. I feel like you
might know possibly that she's watching and you're saying this
to [__] with her. That's really rude. Don't do that.
Do not do that. >> Can you help me find the wallet? Thank
>> what a vibe killer, right, man? What a what a Oh, what
a bring me down Braxton. Okay, this guy. This [__]
guy. >> Throw your ice cream across the [__]
parking lot. >> What a wallet is missing, so I'm looking
for it. That's what's wrong. >> I've been trying to look.
I >> So, you're dancing the music instead of looking. Thank
you. >> I did look,
>> Jesus Christ. >> Don't do that. Then pulls it
on screen. Hey, yes, I did do that. That did happen just now.
>> Like, get the together, man. >> What? I'm not
the one who lost your >> No. I'm saying though that when
>> I have looked in here, I don't see it >> If you
want to play that game, I can also not help you look for [__]
>> Mobilize everything when you do something and then you're
sitting here jamming instead of >> I don't see it. I don't
think it's in >> You're just having a good time, man. What
are you doing? >> Scripted part was it's dark. >> I
said I look
>> No, I said I have a phone, but like I don't see it despite
that. I said I might have missed stuff. There's a lot of things.
Kate, you got to lock in. The wallet's missing. We can't leave.
We can't get our RFIDs. Lock the in. Kate Gar and Lab are lapping
us. I get it. I get it, Nick. I get it. >> Right. It'll
trigger my trauma.
>> Why is your um radar scanner? >> I don't know.
I'm not the one to move. I didn't move anything back there. >> We're
going to hope it's at the place. We're going to go there anyways.
If not, Big L. >> Uh who is that guy who closed his hatch?
That's his driver apparently.
>> Really dumb. Okay, let me explain to you something again.
Ready? The whole point of you staying in the car >> or
streamer couples, the new meta, um I don't know, dude, >> is
for >> it seems like it's like people get into this drama,
but it's like if you want a fruitful relationship, I don't know,
it's probably pretty difficult, >> presumably safety, >> right?
Like to consistently do this kind of content while you're in
a relationship feels difficult.
um doing like content review or doing like a podcast seems different,
but doing like IRL streams where like where you aren't doing
something where you could sit down and like follow like a plan.
I think that's just asking especially with TTS and that's just
asking to have fights, >> So unaware of her surroundings
that there's two guys standing next to your >> It there
we just had the discussion that it's dark.
>> My man, >> it's not like it flares in my peripheral
at all. >> Like like here's the thing. There's no way to
pause this and walk away from each other, right? Like if you're
on stream, but you're on like Discord, somebody can just disconnect
instead of having like an argument. But like for this, there's
no like disconnecting, right? You'd have to go get an Uber or
something. That's already a massive
>> Yes, we we we tapped. >> I did not hear a tap.
You didn't have to bang. You could have just texted me or gone
in front of the car. >> This is where not as much. >> This
is deceptive on camera because it looks so dark because the back
lighting. This is not that dark. I can see right through that.
>> It's pretty dark. Especially the glare from Okay, fine.
You want to You want to play that game? >> I'm not playing.
>> No. No. I'll show you. I'll show you. I'll show you.
Ridiculous.
>> Yeah. I can't see cuz the glare. I see my own reflection
in it. All I see is my reflection. I barely see you at all.
>> All right. Open the door. >> Drop your nonsense
wipe off at home so we can ride the lightning all the way to
the island. >> You can't. It's not going to work if I open
the door.
>> Okay, bro. >> The lightning all the way to the
island. >> You can't. It's not going to >> Okay,
dude. Okay, dude. >> Work if I open. >> Okay, dude.
I see you. I see you. I see >> I open the door. What is
your problem? >> You said you couldn't see. I got to make
>> She's crunching out. >> I'm telling you what I'm
seeing.
>> Oh no. Oh no. >> Try it myself. being toxic. >> No,
I just want to try it. What's wrong,
>> Why can't I see why I can't see out? >> Can't
be in there. You know what I'm
You're playing a stubborn game. >> I told you what I'm
thinking. Why is this so clear to me? Like, holy [__]
dude. This is so clear to me. No, I need you to go out there.
>> I just need to be able to see if I can see you through
it, right? >> I mean, >> can you just do that? >> Just
leave me at home. I don't want to do it anymore. >> I'm
not talking to you right now. No one's talking to you right now.
What do you mean leave you?
>> Leave me at home the entire week and I'm just going
to go home tomorrow. I don't want to do this anymore. >> This
shit's kind of rough content. >> No, I I love that you
cannot be a team player whatsoever.
You literally just suck at my drama and now you're [__]
>> No, no. Hey, I need you to stop being difficult, dude.
>> Okay, we were standing really close. You're trying to
stand far away to make a point and you're trying to support a
point. That's fine, but like that's not You were closer than
this.
>> You think he knows what he's doing or has no idea?
I don't know that he
I don't know that he sees this, right? He might not see this
at all. He might not see like how bad it is at all. No, no, no,
no. Like if you watch the review, but here's the thing. Do we
we all remember when when we got the video from Amaranth of like
what their actual security camera footage was, right? We all
remember this. Like I think there's something really weird going
on with him where he actually can't evaluate these things objectively
in any sense.
Like he we remember when he said this was her like hitting him,
right? Like him domest her domestically abusing him.
>> We remember this, right?
He straight up He straight up told everybody and he was fully
confident when we brought this up on stream that she was the
person physically abusing him here and that she needed to be
the cops needed to be called. He called the
>> No, you cannot disapp
>> Oh, wait. Hold on. There's one more funny thing at the
end here. >> Holding my arm out. God, what a little
What a little snowflake
that. Yes, he was full on ready to call the cops. So, I'm telling
you that there's like something going on here when he's at fault
that he literally cannot visualize or see it at all. Wait, was
he confident or was he narring? Seems very ler of pulling the
clip up, but eventually did. No, no, no. He was totally ready
to pull the clip up. He just couldn't do it. He got They changed
his login. We found out that they really did change the login
to the back end of whatever their Ring camera system was. Okay.
and he couldn't get in.
But he was totally confident and ready to pull it up and he couldn't.
So like when he was when this was on record, he was he watched
this too and he was totally ready to be like, "Yeah, she's she
actually physically assaulted >> You cannot for that. >> Then
on stream, he tried to defend how upset he was about it. So I'm
just saying that like sometimes when he's in the wrong No, no,
no, no, no. He tried to defend himself on the stream.
He literally tried to defend himself on the stream. It was crazy.
By the way, none of this absolves him at all. Right? There's
video evidence. He needs to be he can't do this, right? There's
literally been evidence. People have confronted him with it.
He cannot keep doing it. You can't even if a behavior is involuntary,
you cannot keep doing it over and over and over again. You are
hurting the other person, right? Like there's no excuse for him
to have these like these repeated like domestic
like outright emotional abuse events where he's just screaming
at her. >> No, I know. And like it's not like subtle emotional
abuse either. It's like he's like screaming at her like he's
already at level 11. >> You were close. >> Play the
yell.
>> I feel like we How many viewers did we have for that?
That was incredible content. So many people missed like so much
of the Amaran stuff. That was amazing. That was amazing. >> Stop
asking me to slow down. I know. What I'm saying is that though
you're standing that far away on purpose. Please stop doing that.
We were very close. Now he's like micromanaging the other guy.
Stop standing far so far away on purpose.
>> Wait, wait. I I I still need you to stand over here.
>> Content incoming. >> I need you to stand over
here. >> But you're not going to talk to me like I'm a
piece of [__]
>> Who is talking to you like you're a piece of [__]
>> Yell at me like that, dude. >> Yell at you like
what? You're standing across the thing from me. You want me to
whisper it like this? Like you That's what I'm saying. You stood
so far away that I have to raise my voice just for you to hear
me. If you were against the window, it wouldn't be an issue.
Do you not see that? Like, you're literally standing super far
away. Like, good job >> Like, at least it's I guess at
least it's not just Amaranth. It's like every I don't know. >> I
guess. >> No, you're not. I just want to see if I can see
through the glass. Is that too >> I don't think this was
actually a thing. I think it's totally fine for people to not
like this content. I think it's like kind of trashy content and
it feels like I totally understand why it would feel bad to watch.
I don't mind if people don't like it. I'm just like I I think
it's funny. So, >> you're trying to make a point >> and
you have a problem with me making a point by >> There's
like nothing wrong with people not liking it. >> I want
to see with my own eyes if this is reasonable. >> Okay.
Well, find somebody else to do it for you because honestly, you're
not going to treat me like >> No one is treating me like
a piece of >> I'm a >> What are you talking about?
>> Exactly what you're doing. Stop it.
>> What? What? No way.
What? The camera guy's going. He's going >> If this is
reasonable. >> Okay. Well, >> hold on. I got to back
it up just a little bit more. I got to listen to the build up
again. >> Is that too much to ask? >> You're trying
to make a point. >> And you have a problem with me making
a point? Like I want to see. Look, I want to see with my own
eyes if this is >> Okay. will find somebody else to do
it for you because honestly, you're not going to treat me like
>> No one is treating you like a piece of >> I'm
a >> What are you talking about? >> Exactly what
you're doing. >> Oh, dude, his hands are just bugging.
He's shaking. >> Stop it. >> Which part was the part?
>> The part where you're raising your >> uh So, where
exactly would you say that I was being a Yeah. Where where exactly
would you say that I was being a Okay. What did I say? What did
I say exactly? >> Voice to an unbearable level >> because
you're standing very far away. Just stop
>> because you're standing very far away.
>> Damn, dude. It wasn't that serious.
>> You were very close. >> The wallet is in the rolls.
>> How do you know that? >> Because that's where
you had it last. Y'all jumped out of the rolls and went rolling.
If it's not here, it's in the >> What do you mean we jumped
out of the rolls and went rolling? >> We went straight
to the house. >> No, we came back multiple times for >> I
hear you. It's not here. This all got started over a >> No,
no. I need to be clear about something, okay? Like, is this a
good enough decel? I I just want to make >> This is fine.
This is cool. But start yelling at me and getting angry at me
and putting me in. >> No one is >> I think I literally
So, I don't know for sure and somebody can fill it in. Best I
can tell he was standing outside of the window and trying to
figure out like if a camera would have caught his wallet falling
out of it like when his wallet would have got lost or he asked
amat to do something and she wasn't doing it and so now he's
like trying to prove that it could have been done maybe I've
thought I don't really know why he's trying to take a picture
of this guy like outside of the the window of the roles >> is
yelling at you and we're getting >> no no cool just letting
you know how I feel >> you're raising your voice now >> yes
you're right because it's okay for me can I say what I need to
said, "Go for it." >> Thank you. Now, what I was saying
is this entire altercation could have been
>> Thank you. >> On both parties.
>> So, why are you >> He's trying to prove that Amaranth
should have been able to see him. Okay. Amaranth literally has
her eyes closed. The fastest way to solve this would have been,
"Hey, Amaranth, why don't you roll back?" Or, "Hey, Nick, why
don't you roll back the VOD and just watch that Amaranth has
her eyes closed while she's like jamming to the music?" She literally
couldn't have seen you cuz her eyes weren't open. >> because
I want to see if it is >> For what reason? You can see
right through the window. >> So you agree? No. What is
it?
>> He just wants You're not afraid to speak your mind.
Speak your mind. >> I am speaking. >> He just wants
to win. >> You pay too. You can see right through it. Can
you see through the window? >> Yes. She was zoned in. She
was looking at chat. Don't yell at her for that.
>> Did you not Did you not see her yell at me first?
This isn't Ness's. You banged on the window and scared the [__]
out of her, >> Because you stood there and you're like,
>> don't [__] scared the [__] >> Wait,
wait. Was that him that did it? >> [__] the
window and scared the [__] out of her, bro. >> Because
you stood there and you're like, >> don't [__]
scare the [__] out of her.
>> Oh, that's actually pretty up. I think I think that's
like with I honestly think she's like freaking out because it
seems like that's a trauma response to the
the like mugging, right? Her getting like
urgled. Yeah. Jesus.
And then the guy did it and then the guy just slams the door.
Kimman
live with 157 viewers. Let's go.
Hello. Hello
guys. were watching uh a classic
Nick Wick Lee just started a wife with his sorry just started
a wife with his fight a fight with his wife for no reason.
We're back to Nick Wick Lee picking fights with his wife for
no reason and then turning it into stream content. >> It's
funny that you can bang on it and scare her again to demonstrate.
But
>> yes, you can do it.
>> The guy's like, "No, I feel like a No, I feel like a
I feel really bad. But when I ask you to stand here
>> doing exactly what I said now, please. I don't want
to have to hear both of y'all >> I I really don't like
I really don't like you trying to go out of your way to make
this more complicated. I just wanted to see how reasonable this
is. There's a very practical reason for this because if we are
leaving her in the parking lot alone and she doesn't know when
there's people around the car, that's a problem.
>> Is it not? That defies the whole purpose of having her
in the car.
>> So, I just wanted to see how obvious it >> And
you did it five times, dude. On the outside of the window,
>> now you're going to make me do it and then her do it.
>> No. No. No. No. No. >> Can we stop fighting? >> Can
you not understand something? It's a simple physics thing. I
cannot be outside. I cannot be outside and inside. >> I
have not yet seen for myself what it looks like. Why is that
so hard?
Nick, is that really something that needs to be done? >> Yes,
because if I'm wrong, then I would apologize. And >> do
you think,
>> This is what I'm trying to find out. And you are instead
of You could stand here and this would be done 10 minutes ago,
>> but I stood too far for your liking. >> Well,
it's because you were trying to make the point.
>> You couldn't see me standing five 10 ft more. Can you
not understand that the whole point is is this are these windows
too dark? >> Can you not understand that I did stand there
for you? >> So you're just going to interrupt me now. You
want to go first? Go first. >> It's not what you said,
it's how you say it, bro. >> No, if you start with what
we had the conversation about, I start saying, can you just stand
closer? You go, can you slow down? I go, I just need you to stand
closer.
>> She doesn't want me to comfort her right now. She's
>> asking us to stop me. Man, >> this is all the
So, so just to be clear or just Yeah, just to be clear here,
we go to this.
I'll just set the time to 1 second here. >> I'm I want
>> for the people who just joined, you don't have you didn't
need to see the whole fight, but basically Nick is looking for
his wallet outside of the thing here, right? And he wanted Amaranth
to like answer a question for him. And so, he's like waving at
her and outside of the car, >> right? Maybe not yet, but
watch Amaranth
So, she starts singing.
>> she's singing here. She just starts jamming with her
eyes closed while she's like singing, right? She's not looking
out the window. So, Nick might be signaling her now.
>> And she's not seeing him cuz she's not
>> And he's getting increasingly heated. Increasingly heated.
She's chilling. She's having a good time. He's outside the window.
Hey, notice me. Notice me. Notice me.
Oh my god.
>> And even here, I think she's probably spooked, but she's
not like totally freaked out, right? And he is just like seething
from this moment onward.
>> Next time instead of jamming, help me find the wallet.
Thank you. >> Jesus Christ. >> So that's how the
fight started. Okay, that's how it started. >> I want to
respect him. So, I'm gonna end I I apologize. I'm just gonna
I don't want to deal with that. I don't want to add distress.
I never wanted to add distress. You know that >> I just
asked you to stand outside the window like you were standing
earlier when she didn't see us. >> And that was right against
the >> Dude, he he was just freaking out. He was just freaking
out. He's just He's just mad. He's just angry. Taking it out
on her >> on this one because I don't want to elevate this.
>> How the hell is that elevating anything? >> Because
that's how I feel. So, no. >> I'm sorry. >> Yeah.
But I'm telling you no, I
>> I can see everything that's out here. I >> Everything
that's out here.
>> This blows my mind. >> It literally doesn't It
literally doesn't matter. He's just arguing that she should have
been able to see him, but she literally had her eyes closed.
>> You want to apologize for you banging on it, too, then?
>> Yes, absolutely. Because I just did. I did apologize
for banging on it. >> Crying for views. Shameless people.
>> I don't understand this. >> Look at this. Now,
now y'all can see the lighting. That's proper. You can see
>> The other doors are closed and you just have my one
light on. I mostly just see the reflection cuz the lighting glare.
>> Oh, this one you'll want to demonstrate.
>> Very impartial.
Okay, fine. You close it. You stand here. >> Next. Do you
want me to just [__] quit? >> If you want to.
>> Do you want me to? >> No, no, no. I don't tell
you what to do. >> do you want me to quit? I >> I
don't tell you what to do is what you're pointing. >> Quit.
Do you want me? >> It's just streamed abuse. I mean, it
it is or I
man I go back and forth. It seems pretty
I just I more laugh at Nick. Okay. I laugh at Nick and how he's
kind of [__] up. It's not like I'm laughing at Emmo
crying. Uh we tried to help. We tried to like we tried to we
watched we tried to convince her that like hey he's a total piece
of [__] Is he cosplaying Dr. Disrespect? He is. Yes,
he is.
I don't really I don't laugh at that stuff. It's just um I don't
know >> me too quick. I am asking you a personal >> Do
you want me to just say and go back >> What I want you
to do is stand out here. If you're going to close this door,
>> can you answer me? >> Okay, no problem. Thank
you. >> Going viral is going up. >> You were the
one who got through to Nick during earlier interviews, too. Yeah.
No, that probably didn't happen. >> No, I bought the ice
cream. It's melting, but it's bought. If you need to be comped,
that's fine, but can you take an Uber back to the Airbnb?
Or actually, you know what? I'll pay for your Uber back to your
house.
>> Is that a wise solution? I'm just asking. Why? Because
>> what do we I think I hit him with the gong at some point.
Hold on. Was this the one? I hit him with that one at some point.
Um, but it didn't play through my soundboard or it didn't play
like on the stream, so nobody heard it. Just the just the the
chatters heard it. >> Disrespect.
Disrespect you. You got loud with me, dude. No, >> I don't
get loud with you. I never have. I started off
We even ask about eating dogs, too. That was actually uh
What the [__] I think he might have asked about eating
dogs. >> Y'all too fighting. I don't like that either.
You know that. You've come too far to backtrack. You've done
a lot of healing with your therapy every week. >> Why are
you backtracking? >> No one's backtracking. >> Playing
the doctor disrespect to a team. >> are you not um are
you not seeing
>> Nick? It's a window, dude. You're losing
a fight between you and you're putting me in a position. >> You're
putting me in a position. >> Think about this for a second.
>> Do you not care that you're putting me in a position?
>> I have an employee. >> No, you don't. >> I
have an employee who will not
>> simply stand somewhere so I can see if the windows are
too dark. >> He's crying. I don't like that. She is literally
crying back here. And you want to do that? Come on. >> Oh,
you think Oh, you think me not Ubering you home is going to stop
her from crying? >> I'm sitting here going, "Can you just
leave your driver by the pussy?" >> No, no. You started
off saying, "Can you slow down?" >> I don't get the dumb.
Yes, because you were rapid firing and elevated volume. >> It
wasn't elevated. >> Do and it's like >> when I opened
the window, I said, "Hey, can you stand closer?" And then you
just stood further like like
>> Nick, I don't want to be a part of the argument. This
is insane. You are making me a part of the argument. >> You
stand far enough away that I have to >> I did not like
being part of the argument. I don't like being part of the >> You
done? >> I did not like being part of the >> You
made me a part of the argument. >> We've heard that. We've
heard that. >> Correct. Now, if you're done, like, come
on, dude. >> No, no, no, no. Like, I don't think you >> Take
the part to the tea. Script it. Let's go. Right off dome. >> What
are you talking about? >> This isn't right. And if you're
going to do it for clout and views, that ain't right either.
>> Clout and views. >> You think that >> I
uh Sorry, I've been tapped out for like 2 seconds. I was just
looking at my
>> mod. There's like interesting
interesting stuff going on. Sorry, I need to back it up a little
bit. Let me catch up. >> Art to the tea. Script it. Let's
go. >> Right off Dome. >> What are you talking about?
>> This isn't right. And if you're going to do it for clout
and view >> Oh, I see. I mean, yeah. >> You think
that, >> dude? Wait, isn't isn't this one of their long-term
employees? Somebody said, "Jacob, is this is this the Jacob guy
that's been working for them for a long time? We got any ammo
historians
>> Stand over there so I could see. >> I will send
the greatest force." >> I just don't like that. Is not
that Jacob guy? Okay. Okay. In the back seat, >> tell me
when you're finished so I can >> She climbed in the back
seat, dude. >> Okay. And there's nothing literally trying
to get away from rowing. >> No, because I wanted to try
and sit here and see.
>> We can't both sit in this chair, right? Am I wrong?
You want to crawl crawl over the center console to the driver's
seat? See, you're being nonsensical, dude. Of course, she climbed
to the back seat. She could have come across outside to the back
seat, >> but there's nowhere else to go. I was saying,
"Can I please sit here to see if I can see out the window?" So,
yeah, of course she goes to the back seat. You're trying to play
You're trying to cast a role here. You're saying, "Oh, she's
so scared of me. She in the back seat." No. >> From what
I saw and what I was hearing, >> Well, what about this
logic I just presented to you? >> Okay. Kate, are you doing
okay? Cuz nobody's taking her in this consideration at this moment.
It's me. >> It's fine. >> I don't think you understand.
>> We'll get over it eventually. >> I am far more
pressed about the fact that we're parking this car in places
and she's inside it. This is not the first time. And there can
be people standing right outside and around the car and she's
not going to [__] go. Then I should have never left
the car and I should have sat here with her the entire time.
>> Because I've got a handgun on me. So I could have protected.
>> Do you do you not understand something real fast? It's
that like it's not about whether you left or not. It's more so
about the fact that like if you left and she's actually alert
and she's looking around and she's able to see people outside
her window. >> There was two people standing here. Me standing
right there looking in. >> What's your point? My point
is she was literally just focused on her chat. Bro, I think this
whole argument is stupid and now I'm going to be out of a job
and moving back because of it. >> I asked you very simply.
>> You yelled at me and I I started off by >> No,
you didn't. You weren't at this volume. You were hyped. And I'm
just going to say that flat out. You can disagree with me. That's
cool. I'm not going to you. I'm not going to dress you down.
I apologize that I did yell at you and I did raise my vote. >> Someone
uh give me the initial clip of him coming around >> in
Discord. Please, >> you got to see how you're putting me
in the middle of this by telling me because you pay me right
that I have to do everything and bend to the whim when I shouldn't
be in this and this really shouldn't be happening. >> You
are painting a picture that isn't what I'm trying to achieve
here. >> Oh, you're going to interrupt me again. I thought
you were done. >> I'm not. Kate, don't do that [__]
to me. >> You're not. Kate, don't do that so I can do that
[__] to her. Stop it. >> You do it all the
time.
>> You said I was interrupting you, didn't you interrupt
me? Are you done? >> We literally just Y'all just had this
one at the Airbnb. >> Finish talking then so that I can
speak. How about that? >> You go first. So, you're done.
So, I can speak now. >> I'm just not allowed to respond.
It's a four-dimensional chess game me. >> I'm literally
You >> Nick has never lost an argument. Okay. That's because
you only lose an argument if you leave. All right. As long as
you stay, the other person leaves. You win. You win every time.
>> Interrupt me every time. Goick. >> I say, "Well,
get whatever you have off your chest first and then you say
>> Okay, I'll open up first. Do you not see how if she
actually can't see outside the window?
>> Look at that. >> Oh, cool. How's it going? >> Hey,
how are you? >> You guys all right? >> Yeah. Can
you Can you help me with something real fast? >> Yeah,
sure. >> Stand right against this window. I'm going to
close it. Okay. >> It's it's a it's a it's a I just want
>> just need to know. Basically, what happens when he gets
out the window? >> Right. That's a problem cuz we're leaving
and she wants to stay inside for
>> He's getting a stranger to do it now. He's found he's
enlisted at the help of a stranger. >> And so me and Badger
are right outside where you are there, right?
>> And she says she can't see you. >> I kind of don't
believe that. But you know, if it's true, these are way too tinted
and something needs to change. >> Right. Um, if I can see
you, well then context Ice put a chest there. Oh no. Do I need
to go watch Ice Besides POV? Yes. At some point here, Ice Boseidon
starts watching Nick having this fight. And because he can see
how how far away from paying attention Nick is, he drops a chest
on top of them to see if they'll grab it.
Right.
Hold on. Can we find Ice Pesidon's POV? This is 3 days ago. Hold
on. Ice Poseidon. Or is this the ice POV? Hold on. Did somebody
link the ice POV or was that just Nyx? Where is it? This is Nyx.
Can we see the ice POV? Oh, I I'm gonna have a hard time finding
this exact thing. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. His ice is still
online. Give me a second. I'll look. I'll look. We'll see if
we can find a clip. Give me a second. Give me a second. Clips
last week. Yes. Yes. Where's him watching Amaranth and Nick?
That's not them. That's Gary David. Nick is poor. No. No. No.
No. That'd be somebody else. Come on. Show me clips of him watching
Amaranth and Nick. Come on. Nothing. Nothing.
>> Yeah, apparently three days ago. VOD from two or three
days ago.
>> I'm scanning. I'm just gonna We'll find it if it's here.
It's night time, so got to be the VOD before.
>> I don't see them fighting at all.
>> Scanning. I'm looking. Not finding.
>> Hold on. And I'll see if I've got it in the 1322. What?
The VOD before this, I think. Oh, 13 hours 22 minutes.
>> Ah, yes. >> [__] out of >> Why
are you continuing? >> Because I want to see if it is reasonable
to see. >> Reason you can see right through the >> So
from next POV, ice watching next POV. >> Oh, now see what
is this >> massive content? >> You said you're not
afraid to speak your mind. Speak your mind. I am speaking my
>> So you say too, you can see right through it. Can you
see through the >> Yes, she was zoned in. She was looking
at chat. Don't yell at her for that. >> Fire him, Nick.
>> Did you not Did you not see her yell at me first? >> Why
is the driver yelling at the guy who's paying him >> on
the window and scared the [__] out of >> Because
you stood there plus viewers now. Nick W. Nick.
>> Oh god.
>> It's funny that you can bang on it and scare her again
to demonstrate, but you >> Dude, I can't find >> Yes,
you can do it by tomorrow. When I ask you to stand here, >> there
it is. Jesus. >> When I get to hear about my music,
>> I really don't like you trying to go out of your way
to make this more complicated. I just wanted to see how reasonable
this is. There's a very reason for this because if we are leaving
her in the parking lot alone and she doesn't know when there's
people around the car, that's a problem. Is it >> They
have to fight the whole purpose of having her in the car. >> I'm
stupid. >> So, I just want to see how obvious it >> And
you did it five times who on the outside of the window. What's
going on? >> You're going to make me do it and then her
doing it. >> No. No. No. No. >> Can we stop fighting?
>> Can you not understand something?
I cannot be outside. I can't be outside and inside. I have not
yet seen for myself what it looks like.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. >> Yes. Because if I'm wrong, then
>> where is he on the map? >> I apologize. And >> you
think you're wrong?
>> You look like he's being Dr. Dre and you are in you
could stand here and this would be done 10 minutes ago. >> But
I stood too far for your liking. >> Well, because you were
trying to make the point. >> We've already listened to
this. I'm just speeding through a little bit. I mean, I would
I wouldn't give a [__] as long as you pay me. I don't
care how you talk to your wife. >> You know, >> I
just asked you to stand outside the window like you were standing
earlier when she didn't see us and that was right in this window,
right? >> How the hell is that? >> Because that's
how I feel. >> Cuz just eating a muffin now. >> I
can see everything that's out here. I can see everything that's
out here. This blows my [__] mind.
>> You want to? >> Driver's like, I apologize. I'm
so sorry for this. And Nick is like, I can see everything. There's
no way you couldn't see me. >> Apologize for you banging
on it too >> Yes, absolutely. >> Okay. The visibility
is very easy. Okay. >> Crying for views. Shameless people.
I don't understand this. Look at this now. Now y'all can see
the lighting. That's proper. You can see everything. >> Their
doors are closed and you just have my one light on. I mostly
didn't see the reflection cuz the light glare. >> Oh, this
one you'll want to demonstrate. Nice. Very impartial. Okay.
>> Not very fair of you to go and help her demonstrate
her point. Not very fair of you, bro. >> Do you want to?
>> Do you want me to? >> I don't tell you what to
do. Remember, >> do you want me to quit? >> I don't
tell you what to do is what your point is. >> Quit. Do
you want me to quit? I'm asking you a personal question. >> Moving
so fast. >> Say [__] it and go back home. >> What
I want you to do is stand out here. If you're going to close
this door, >> can you answer me? >> Let me put it
I'm going put a chest on >> Views going up. >> $250
chest right on top of him. Let's see. Here we go. >> this
happened because he didn't want to buy ice cream. >> No,
I bought the ice cream. It's melting. But
>> if you need to be comped, that's fine. But can you take
an Uber? >> Content Nick. >> Or actually, you know
what? >> I mean, he ain't going to know that it's there.
He ain't going to get a discount. He ain't going to He ain't
going to know. But someone else will figure it out and go drive
over. >> I'm just asking. And what is the purpose of that?
Why? Because >> Nick, like a true doctor, disrespect. >> Trying
to disrespect you. You got loud with me, dude. I don't get loud
with you. I never have. I don't like that. >> Y'all too
fighting. I don't like that either. You know that. You've come
too far to backtrack. You've done a lot of healing with your
therapy every week. Why are you backtracking? >> No one's
backtracking.
>> Don't talk about Don't talk about that on the stream,
bro. You go to therapy. Why are you backtracking? What kind of
driver is >> I would just be I'd be like, "Bro, who the
[__] are you? >> I won't stand where you want
me to." >> Like, that's not your forte, bro. That's not
your job. >> Because it's the >> It's causing a fight
between you and >> it's a tiny They all got loud. >> It's
a tiny >> You're putting me in a position. >> Think
about this for a second. >> Do not care that you're putting
me in a >> I have an employee. >> No, you don't.
>> I have an employee who will not simply stand somewhere
so I can see if the windows are too dark. >> Fire him,
Nick. >> She is literally crying back here. And you want
to do that? Come on. >> Oh, you think Oh, you think me
not Ubering you home is going to stop her from crying? >> I'm
sitting here going, "Can you just >> grab your driver by
the pussy?" >> No, no. You started off saying, "Can you
slow down?" >> I don't get the dumb. Yes, because you were
rapid
firing and elevated volume. >> It wasn't elevated.
>> And it was like >> when I opened the window, I
said, "Hey, can you stand closer?" And then you just stood further
like like >> Nick, I don't want to be a part of the >> guy's
like me on the playground is like an 8-year-old
playing like Mech Warrior.
What was it called? What was it called on um the first is it
Mecca? What was the first game on Xbox?
Right. You have your your arms are guns.
I remember making these sound effects as a little kid. What's
is it Mecca Assault the first game on the Xbox? And you're like
a Timberwolf walking around with the big guns on your shoulders,
big missile launchers. Let's go.
>> Making me a part of the argument. >> You stand
far enough away that I have to not like being part of the argument.
>> No. No. Oh, you got to wait until I switch to the No,
you're wrong. You're wrong. No, you got to wait until I switch
to the me machine guns. Okay. You don't even know. You don't
even know about the gun sounds I make. Okay. >> Heard that.
Correct. Now, if you're
>> come on, dude. >> Looks like uh I only see one
person >> Try to get that chest and it looks like >> What
are you talking about? >> Tazo's so far away. If Tazo gets
this chest, if Tazo gets this check, this chest that's dropped
on top of Nick, he should get like $10,000 for that. That would
be crazy. You know that's I mean that's free money. >> I
would drive over it. It's free money. >> Drivers aren't
supposed to talk. Tell them to drive or I will send the greatest
force this world. >> I don't even know what they're about.
>> He's they're arguing cuz he yelled at her so I can speak
>> about something and then she crying and then the driver's
getting all pissed. >> There's nothing >> 85 viewers
and growing. >> No, because I wanted to try and sit here
>> drop a treasure chest on you. >> You can't both
get in this chair, right? Am I wrong? You want to crawl crawl
over the center console to the driver's seat? >> Dude,
no way. He doesn't even hear it at >> Sensical, dude. Of
course, she climbed in the back seat. She could have come across
outside of the back seat, but there's nowhere else to go. >> I
was saying, "Can I please sit here to see the other drive?" So,
yeah, of course the back would like you're trying to cast a role
here. You're saying, "Oh, she's so scared of me. She's from the
back seat." No. >> From what I saw and what I was hearing
>> Well, what about this logic I just presented to you?
>> Okay. Kate, are you doing okay? >> Cuz nobody's
taking her into consideration at this moment. >> It's fine.
>> I don't think you understand. >> We'll get over
it eventually. I am far more pressed about the fact that we're
parking this car in places and she's inside it. This is not the
first time. And there can be people standing right outside and
around the car and she's not gonna [__] >> dude.
Oh my god. I made the chest one meter distance away. So Tazo's
got to get super close.
>> Dude, that explains Sorry. That explains why Tazo's
the guy who's there.
>> Dude, no way.
>> No way. stand
and now I'm going to be out of my >> dude. No way. >> I
asked you very simply. >> Dude yelled at me. >> No,
I I started off by asking. >> No, you didn't. You weren't
at this far. You were hyped. And I'm just going to say that flat
out. You can disagree with me. That's cool. I'm not going to
>> Dude, he has to loop all the way around the parking
lot. >> No way.
>> Dude, this is like Hold on. This is like the best content
of the entire scavenger hunt. How is this not clipped and put
on like every platform that exists that like this guy is so into
fighting with his wife that somebody's about to come and snatch
a $250 chest from out from under him like instantly >> him
coming around in Discord. >> You got to see how like you
and I did raise my >> Someone uh give me the initial clip
of him coming around in Discord, please. You got to see how you're
putting me in the middle of this by telling me because you do
pay >> 1,000 please. >> I have to do everything,000.
>> I'm not [__] >> 250. Oh, lame. I'm
too far away from the chest. What do you mean? >> There
is a domestic situation happening. >> He's got to be right
on top of the car. >> He's got to be right on top of the
car. >> Again, what's the point? >> He's got to walk.
He's got to walk right up to the car. Oh, >> finish talking
then. >> 6 me away. >> I can speak, >> dude.
No way. >> I mean, it's right on Nick.
>> So, I can speak now.
>> You loved
dimensional chest. >> Ah, he got it in the store. [__]
>> you.
Too bad. Whatever you have off your chest first and then you
say nothing. >> Not accurate. >> Okay, I'll open
up. >> Yeah. No, it's the white truck. It is right there.
>> That's literally That's literally their Rolls-Royce
right there. Yes.
That rolls that he walks by right here, that's them >> of
this by telling me >> he's got to walk over. I'll walk
right up to >> an argu.
Oh, he goes and actually starts talking to them. Hold on, dude.
>> Hey, how you guys? All right. >> Yeah. Can you
help? >> Yeah, sure. What's up, >> man? Right against
this window. I'm going to close it. Okay. >> It's it's
a I just need to know. Basically, what happens is >> She's
saying she can't see outside the >> Right. That's a problem.
>> Do you think Nick even recognizes Tazo? Do you think
Nick has any idea that this is Tazo? >> He is in the white
car and arguing. >> Stay inside for safety. So, me and
Badger are right outside where you are there. I see >> and
she says she can't see you. >> I kind of don't believe
that, but you know, if it's true, these are way too tinted and
something needs to change. >> Right. Um, if I can see you,
well, then it's just that she wasn't paying attention. And if
that's the case, then you should probably >> How is this
guy so have so much energy? At least we're >> 3 o'clock
in the morning. >> I have some ideas on why he might have
that much energy. This guy Nick's got to be on something, bro.
>> That is between
>> Oh,
sorry. >> So, that's all right. So, the it was too tinted
or something. She couldn't see. >> So, I want to I want
I'm going to raise it and I'll see if I can see you. >> Okay.
Yeah, if it's possible or not. Oh, yeah. That's all right. A
good experiment. All right. No problem. >> I mean, I can
see myself through the reflection. So, >> all right. Should
I Should I leap or something? I don't know what's I don't know
what's going on. I can read.
>> I can't see through the back windows.
>> That's right. Maybe the back ones are tuned more tuned.
Oh, okay. Well, >> yeah. Um, yeah, it's mainly because
like you're standing in front of the thing which we were standing
in front of and you can see very clearly because backlighting,
right? >> Right. Of course.
>> yeah. Okay. Well, what's what's the solution? It's just
that >> Oh, no. I just feel like >> like the mediator
now. >> It truly is too tinted. Then we >> just wanted
to get his 250 and leave. >> Okay. I mean, but for safety,
you probably don't want people to know who's in the car sometimes
or privacy or >> It's true, but like it it backfires. And
they agreed earlier that like at night >> I mean at least
it's right. Imagine if it was like >> I seem like it seems
like a great level of tensing because it prevents it creates
but also >> you can see. >> Mhm. Fair enough. Yeah.
>> Except you're saying that you can't see. >> Do
you want to try it again? >> You can sit here. >> Well,
maybe when you're looking at a bright phone screen and then you
look away, it's hard to >> the case. But can you not understand
that like if you want to be in the parlo like situational awareness
clips? >> Unless you should give me more money. Oh, isn't
that the isn't that like the argument here, too? Nick was like,
do you remember Nick being like, "You have to follow me right
now. It's super important you follow me right now because there's
some situational awareness thing. It's really important."
>> You even
>> What's the risk of not getting out of line of sight?
>> You can't
do this on you.
>> Do not
>> it was like Nick's like fully fully bought into the
whole Andrew Tate thing like oh this is a safety issue. Okay,
you're not paying attention. It's a safety issue very well. >> Hey
man, >> that was probably the content door. Okay, like
I was just going to get out. No, stand. Watch. >> Thank
you for being >> all right chat clip clip of the Well,
>> I turned around and said, "What are you doing?" And
then like what? Oh, okay. Like like I saw you closing. H
run away. Should I leave? >> Sorry about that. >> That's
all right. Oh, no. That's all right. But you guys all right or
we're >> Okay. I'll see you tomorrow then or >> I
want to hold you off. >> Oh, that's I've got nothing to
do. I'm just going to go sleep anyway, I >> But where do
you sleep? >> Um just around the corner. It's like the
>> Oh, just holiday in. I should probably change to an
Airbnb because I need to get out of the house or into a car much
faster than like going through elevators to get out. But anyway,
it's fine. Yeah. >> Really been nice. >> Doing my
best. Yeah. All right. Um well, good luck to you. >> All
right. Are you guys staying long? doing more clues or or what?
>> I'm going to drop them back off the >> at this
point trying to bought a bunch of stuff to try >> for the
swimming challenge. >> Yeah. Oh my gosh. >> H fair
enough. Well, yeah. Either way, maybe do it in the daylight then
you can see what you're doing more and then you can catch up
with me. >> Yeah, fair enough. >> All right. >> Yeah.
Sorry about the uh >> Oh, yeah. No problem. Don't worry
about it. Thanks for helping out earlier. All right. All right.
See you around. DJs scammed. Oh, sorry. My volume was down. >> I
put another chest down. >> What was the DGS >> on
top of Nick's crying in the back? I don't want to be in >> say
what amount
these at all. Come on. I want more money than that. >> Come
on, Ta. You >> won't
I put another chest right next to him, bro. >> We'll go
back. We'll go back to the
>> when he clicks on it. But
quickly. Oh my goodness. Is I still streaming? Oh, he's still
streaming. >> There's a new ch. Oh, where? Where? Where?
Oh my god. Oh, god damn it. Refresh. Where? Where? Where?
The same >> One more chance on Nick. >> Wait. He
wanted me to go back out. Is it like $1? He's He's going to give
me like a dollar or something. Oh, $25. You son >> Jesus.
250. That's not enough to cover your puncture tire. >> I'm
gonna have to Yeah. Think of my puncture tire.
>> You put it right on the [__] car, didn't
you? >> The either of them must have adicted
>> I mean, we'll probably just keep watching this to be
honest. Honestly, just go back to their um cuz we have Tazo.
Tazo's still talking to them. Tazo $25.
You put it right on the >> Bro, all those all those people
pulled up for $25.
>> Everyone see it for $25. >> What am I I'm doing
is >> I'm dropping chests that are like $500 each, bro.
I should be dropping $20 chest, man. The same outcome. >> I
think it's chicken. >> It's the same outcome.
>> Yeah, I know. It's fine. Uh this this >> is it
just fine >> is way darker than in real life. >> Did
I just put a rest around here? >> You know what? I think
I can demonstrate this. Okay, I got it. >> Why would it
be important to demonstrate this? Nobody can get it through this
guy that it like it literally doesn't matter. It's a totally
inconsequential fight. There's no reason to be fighting on this
at all. >> Let's put that duct tape. >> Everything
that comes out. >> Yo, what the >> Hey, what's up?
No, no, you're good. You're good. I'm just getting some back.
>> All right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know. He's dropping.
>> Are you
>> He's like getting all the kicksters to come and intervene
in this guy's
>> So, when you agree with me, you get to be right, too.
>> Okay, let's speed it through. Let's speed through this
if they're going to pause for a little bit. >> It's not
bad at all. Like, it's overly
>> They're literally all
the hell out of >> She's still just quietly crying the
whole time. >> While Nick is like networking with all of
these people.
>> Feel like a Yeah.
You think >> this makes it impossible to see here, right?
But you can still see it's spearmint. Like you can see the big
letters pretty easy. Oh, that's
going to make it >> like it's literally visible in every
>> Dude, not apologize. >> Has to prove his point
above what his wife's literally saying cuz he doesn't believe
her. He wants to have reasonable
justification for veganism. >> Is it not reasonable for
me to want to see with my own eyes? Is it not reasonable? I'm
asking you. >> But you can see you already know how to
be agree with God. You're so important to this. >> I'm
asking you. Sorry, this just popped up in my timeline. Am I supposed
to care about this Willy Mac thing? I have no idea what's going
on. Eight comments, four likes. Yeah, he's got a succession >> Is
it reasonable? >> Well facts. >> So, I'm not allowed
to see for myself. Is that right? >> No, that's just his
ringtone. This his normal ringtone content of the year, content
king. You've already said that while you were driving even >> that
was Can you not understand that when I'm driving and I'm staring
down a dark road so there's there's darkness behind the window.
It is a whole different situation than when there's a whole store
illuminating and shining through the window. Can you see Can
you understand that? >> The store is behind us. >> No,
it's beside us. >> No, it's not. >> Are you kidding?
>> It's even the back window. It's behind the window. >> Are
you kidding me right now? >> No, it is not beside the front
seat. It is behind it. >> Okay, if that's the hill you
want to die on. All right, guys. We are in the car. >> Hello.
But by every word that comes out of the mouth of Nick. >> I
don't know, man. If >> No, no, Sophia. It's not solved.
It's not solved because what they what she said and what Nick
said was, sorry, what she said was actually when all the lights
are out inside. Okay. Only one side the driver side light is
on. Then it's too reflective and you can't see out. So, it's
not solved. >> Close the window. >> She keeps arguing.
>> The reason why you keep popping the cry show is because
you're not correct. Why you want to achieve what you wanted the
first time? It's still Walgreens. >> I think we've established
that the store is more beside us than it is behind us. We can
try this. >> I just grabbed some leftovers out of my fridge.
I walked around my entire house trying to figure out where the
I put my hot sauce and it was in my computer room like right
next to my streaming setup. God damn it. I like it wasn't I didn't
put it back in the fridge last night.
>> We can try if you want. >> Shut the [__]
up. It doesn't matter. I cannot see. Well, sitting there
is a good woman. >> If I told you, let's say your dog is
>> Fine. You're >> I cannot see you. >> You
can't see either. Therefore, it's too dark. >> Fine. My
>> This doesn't matter. Go. >> Are you done yelling
at me? >> No, I'm not. >> Is it okay for you to yell
at me? >> Please. You've already taken my VGC. >> Can
we take it down a notch? >> No, I can't because you won't.
>> Different hot sauce. >> I'm hungry. >> Is
there no way back home? >> Is there no way? >> Do
I have to Uber back to the airplane myself? This is ridiculous.
Is there no way you can stop yelling? >> Only if we go
back home, we can Airbnb. >> So, it's just ultimatum. >> Well,
there you have it. She can yell at me. I'm not allowed to yell
at her cuz apparently, you know, whatever imaginary rule you
want to fight against.
>> I know. >> No, you were talking.
>> Can you
uh Kelly just made a bunch of up. But go ahead, Destiny. If you
if you think if you think Kelly's trustworthy, okay, she said
some stuff about you,
>> It's not here,
>> Kelly. when she talks about Destiny's girlfriend's hemorrhoids.
Very untrustworthy. Kelly, when she talks about my girlfriend,
super trustworthy. Apparently. Apparently. Apparently. >> Go
back to the [__] farm. >> You don't even care
about my safety. >> You are literally >> You don't
give a [__] You left the door open the last time
you quit. You [__] >> I sit here. She get leans
up and [__] yells at me. >> I'm sorry. >> I'm
guessing you have a problem and act like you're a hero. >> Because
when when I am raising my voice, not even at that. >> I
have a problem with you. >> But you're never going to >> I
be super specific, but I'm going to wait for her to be done.
>> [__] say anything. I have it. I am saying
it right now. I have a problem with both of it. You as a man
>> should treat your wife better. My opinion. Don't like
it, like it, don't care. My opinion. >> And my opinion
is that you should probably Uber back. >> But honestly,
we all work this out. No. >> until you relax. >> Read
these leaks. I think you got to go to Destiny's stream. >> I
really don't. >> guys? J is obsessed with me. He's so obsessed
with me. >> You'll say nothing. I barely raise my voice.
It's like, can you stop yelling at me? >> She's asking
for peace. >> Can you not see that she's yelling in my
>> Yes. I can't. You want me to go against what I just
said about being a man and not yelling at the woman? I get it.
Okay, you're right. He is right. You shouldn't yell that. Plain
and simple. You should not yell at her. Plain and simple, dude.
That's that's just that's just how I feel. That's my heart speaking
and it hurts. That hurts my heart because I want to see the happen.
Go ahead. Fire me. I don't really give a because I wanted to
see y'all [__] I like seeing the
out of here.
>> You're right. It is a >> Go ahead. Like, >> come
on, dude.
I really can't have someone who if I asked them to replicate
the situation we were just in. Cannot do that. >> When
I said you saw me, >> are you good? Do you do you need
help, >> A domestic argument between your wife. >> No,
you both. >> You've watched this entire stream tonight.
I guess we watch He's just looking for friends. He's just looking
for friends.
>> I'm glad that you and Kelly are back on the same team,
though. Good luck to both of you, J. Destiny. You guys deserve
each other. >> No. Yes. You said it. Yes. You're going
to be doing work for her. Yes, you're going to be doing work
for you. I'm going to be focusing more on you. That's not what
I said. She won't be asking. Yes, it is. That is your words verbatim.
>> Do you want to check the employment contract or did
you not read that? >> What employment contract? >> You're
not employed. >> You had me fill out my 1099 form and we
started going from there. There was no contract other than me
putting down what I needed for my tax. >> So, you're saying
is you are not an employee currently. You've gotten a 1099. Can
you give me that makes me an employing you? Can you That's Nope.
The 109 literally defined as not an >> What does it define
me? >> A contractor. A contractor for what
>> I just want to be >> Okay, then. And who are the
owners of that company? Doesn't >> matter. No, no, no.
Okay, we have another [__] Jacobike situation now.
>> You want No, no, no. Is Destiny ready? Listen, Destiny,
I'll answer your questions. If you just post any evidence you
have of me participating in doxing, me encouraging doxing, queen
encouraging doxing, queen doing any doxing. You just post any
evidence you have of us trying to go after your friends in any
way like this. Okay? Just any evidence you got. I'm psyched to
see it. Now that you're here, I would love to know. Surely you
have evidence for the basalosa accusations, right? Surely you're
going to post any evidence at all. Or are you just going to go
on stream and make skits drawings again? I'd love if you just
posted some evidence. Anything? Anything at all? >> Yeah,
I did. And you clearly didn't rocket someone. >> You're
trying to now. >> No, I can spinning it. I'm spinning it.
You're spinning it. Are you done? You're >> Can I speak?
>> You're spinning. >> Why are you a Mongorian?
>> Uh, we are hoorde. That's why we are Mongorian. You
can spit a false narrative all you like and try to get 600 700
1500 2,000 people believe you. But my opinion I gave you verbatim.
You won't look at either one of your cameras. You got this on
me instead of on you to see your >> This one's on me. >> No,
it's not. Your face ain't on it. >> Your face ain't on
it. Boo Bear. >> This is nuts. You won't stand here and
address me. But I can't turn around and address you. >> I
should be able to say no. >> No. No. I get that. >> If
you make me uncomfortable, I should be able to say no because
this situation was heated. I didn't like it. You put me in the
middle of it and now we're doing
>> Do you not see that there is a issue? Do >> I
wonder He's probably not going to stick around, but it would
be funny to go over his latest um what do you call it? His latest
allegation, right? Hold on. Which one was it? It's the um
this one. Oh, hold on. What? Oh, this is from February. Yeah,
I felt bad when she tweeted publicly about me and I told a friend
about it. Does this back up anything that's being said? This
is me saying, "Oh, yeah. I felt bad that this happened." And
yeah, sorry. I I literally had a sick family member and I was
not focusing on that enough.
Wow. Uh let's see what else she said.
I didn't say she was lying about everything she's she said. I
just saw most of the stuff today. Most of the stuff about Cherry
is just lies, right? Cuz she's actually mad at Cherry and not
me.
Well, she might be mad at me now after the comment about her
boyfriend breaking down the door or whatever. Or her breaking
down her boyfriend's door. But she was mad at Cherry in the first
place. I don't know why he's framing this as me going after Cherry.
You literally are what? How is she trying to say it's not going
after Cherry? Literally Kelly loing out is Destiny's proof that
something happened apparently. Does he know when these messages
were from by the way? His defense is Kelly. Oh, whoops. We read
this one. If you think Sunday was on Jtock's side, you might
have to read further. Lol. But I know what kind of person he
is now. Jock will accuse me of lying when he knows I am not actually
a of a person.
Hold on. This is Kelly saying this. Moon Ray Murray just tipped
$5. Unban me,
>> Unban me, please. Sure. Moon Ray Murray, unbanned piece
of information.
Oh, yeah. This is like just a blatant lie. Like a clear and blatant
lie. Hold on.
That one was a lie. This is also just a complete lie. Just a
complete and utter lie. Both of these two are just complete and
utter lies. One's easily disproven. She's saying this happened
at a VC. There's no way for me to disprove that. But I I don't
know. I guess you just have to find other people who said I thought
this at any point. But uh this one's easily disproven. But then
but then she also will say that well actually if I disprove it,
it just proves that I lied to her directly.
So there's just no reason to engage with this person. The cow's
out of milk now. And that was why I just I just told her like
leak everything you know about me right now cuz I just I don't
want to sit here and be like when is she going to make something
up? When is she going to try to tip some drama over by trying
to leak something about me? So I just said Kelly leak everything
you know right now. Just say everything you got. Empty everything
you got out. What is this for the listeners? Oh uh is Kelly logs.
So she said she said that Cherry flew here without me telling
her my address or asking permission like that asking for his
address first. That's obviously insane. That obviously didn't
happen. Does this change anything Destiny did? It doesn't. It
It literally doesn't. But he's he's just trying to like weaponize
his audience to go after people, right? Trying to see. Do we
have any other messages here that I missed? This is Oh, that
was why Kelly was mad. It was cuz I got rid of the emotes.
Sorry. Food Chops was posting in chat. Jesus Christ.
Yeah. I don't know. Out of these things, like I delete my DMs
with Kelly. So, like here's the thing of February where was like
upset about um I was like I sad posted to like three friends
about this which is embarrassing. It is. It's sad that I that
I trusted Kelly, right? Embarrassing, but realistically
this is just me feeling bad for myself, right? Is this this is
like the worst of it? Okay. Hm.
Okay. When they started dating, they were dating at least as
early as February. Literally not true, even remotely. Also easily
disproven. But aren't you fine? I literally I say right here
why I was upset, right? It was like I had a lot of going on.
I had a family member who had cancer. I talked about this on
stream right in January. I had a family member was like very
sick. And instead of like spending as much time as I should have
with my family, I was
like involved in like internet stuff, which was stupid. And that
felt stupid. But I took care of that. We fixed that. We're all
good now. Well, also by the way, by the way, like venting about
my family member dying to Kelly and how up I was about like cherry
posting about me and venting about that was literally
what I knew she had to leak on me
>> and now it's out there and I don't have to care anymore.
I don't have to go around that person anymore. Right. That's
why that's why I said that's why I just said like leak whatever
you've got. Go hard cuz I'm done with you. And I don't I'm not
even going to attack her back. I don't have to attack her back.
She can do whatever she wants. I don't care. Um, once I'm confident
she's done like leaking [__] about me, I'll just
post the counter evidence I have to show that she's just making
up like where she is making [__] Obviously,
obviously this was the thing. And that's why that's why I didn't
think she could go after Cherry even cuz I assumed that she was
just going to go and be like, "Oh, you're super embarrassing.
You were like you were like super upset about this. I just thought
that's all it was going to be, but it wasn't." Anyway, no, it's
very sad. M
Yeah, I don't know. It is what it is. Oh, it's a substance tweet.
Destiny acts like he hasn't partly built his career off of having
dedicated clippers and Twitter. I mean, he has. He has. I weaponized
my clips and clippers by clipping actual factual arguments about
politics, not obsessing weirdly over losers personal lives. When
have his clippers like gone and done this? When have Queen's
clippers gone and done this? He just tells him to clip his content.
Yeah. No, I understand that this is there's the August post and
then there's another one. There's a thinking monk post. They
both said this, right? Da clips discord has become the omni liberal
brain room and it's literally about how they can maximize the
effectiveness of like his clips and stuff. Yeah, you're not wrong.
Alien mode. I just didn't think she'd like lie about to do that.
That's all. Like this. Yeah, I just didn't think she'd lie about
it. It's just sad. But whatever. There's no way he's like hyping.
No, he's definitely hyping Kelly. He's been hyping Kelly, but
it's it's fine. Kelly wants to go after Cher. She's not even
proving anything about anybody but She's not proving anything
about anybody. Yeah, she's like 100% aligned with Destiny. That's
fine. Honestly, like her leaking embarrassing about me again
was just like the only thing I was like a little concerned about.
And I have no interest in like counterfiring on this or anything.
She can just go off and rejoin DG chat if she wants. Yeah, the
brain room is where they get together to craft top tier replies.
Like, I'm not a Destiny fan, but you should have them on more
often. Yeah, this is the other thing. I get put on the side of
spicy chat and those guys have hated me for a long time because
I like Destiny. She actually crash out on you. No. Well, she
was like adding me and I don't remember what she said, but I
responded like, "Oh, this person's like kind of obsessed with
me and my door can't take her being obsessed with me, right?"
Referring to like her going to her ex's house. And that set her
off completely. But me and Syo are best friends,
obviously. Why is Destiny always bringing up and pretending he's
revealing this new thing that happens on the internet? Guys,
they're doing this clip this thing of clipping and shipping.
Yeah, that's crazy. Your first mistake was trusting Kelly. I
know. I know. Listen, I thought it would be weird to go and talk
to people in real life about my family members being sick or
whatever. My my stepdad being sick. I just thought that would
be weird, okay? cuz I hadn't been I had been keeping like super
I had been keeping up with communication with um a couple of
my friends and then my two best friends two friends who had been
best mans at their wedding um they both moved so just felt weird.
So I I happened to talk to Kelly cuz I was hanging out with Kelly.
Okay, that's the way it is. That's how it is.
But like also I feel like there's probably a lot of other people
online who would have been able to who would have been able to
talk about like this thing. Unlucky. Also, I just want to point
out Okay, I just want to point out apparently she has these screenshots
on her phone. Now, why would she have these screenshots on her
phone precisely? I have no idea. I really don't. I really don't.
I don't know why she'd have these screenshots on her phone. No,
I think Tony talked about this thing as well, but like it is
what it is. Sorry, I'm just reading these logs again. I don't
even know what she's leaking. Oh, something about Discord servers.
Let's see here. I'm I'm just reading these off stream cuz I I'm
not going to I'm not putting them all on stream probably. Oh,
I was just like I just wanted her to leak whatever she has cuz
again, like I said, I'm just I feel like um
she'd come and talk and then she always is like trying to hold
this thing over my head like that. I was uh despondent in February
over stuff. I'm just reading through. Yeah, nothing. I l
There's nothing there. Okay. All right. Good enough. This is
such a weird Yeah. I I don't know why she's trying to like
I don't know. I don't know.
But again, this is the thing I was actually worried about. Um
it's weird that she went after Cherry first cuz that's like clearly
who she was actually upset at. Whatever. What's up, Buggy? How's
it going? looking at DM leaks, but we're done with that now.
And we're back to watching Amaranth and Nick Lee. Oh boy. Let's
go. >> There's an issue. Stop with the acting. >> Let's
Let's drag it back about a minute >> What you'd like and
try to get 700, 1500, 2,000 people to believe you. I >> chill
to keep stream going. Uh guys, we are five subs away. Five subs
away from another hour in the stream. >> Opinion, I gave
you verbatim. You won't look at either one of your cameras. You
got this on me instead of on you to see your dude. >> No,
it's not. Your face ain't on it, boo. Your face ain't on it,
Boo Bear. This is nuts. You won't stand here and >> By
the way, I have access to none of my logs with Kelly as well
because I am not on my main account and I'm a main account. So,
>> trust me, >> I can't turn around and address you.
>> I should be able to say no. >> No, no, I get that.
>> If you make me uncomfortable, I should be able to say
no because this situation was heated. I didn't like it. You put
me in the middle of it and now we're doing >> Do you not
see that there is a issue? >> Do you not see that there's
an issue? >> Stop with the acting for me. >> What
are you talking about? You want Let me finish the sentence. What
do you What acting? Okay. So, that's what I'm talking about.
You do that a lot. You're very animated. >> That's You're
extremely animated >> and you're very low energy. You do
it. No, I'm not low energy. Trust me.
>> Now, though, now I can actually go and and uh >> Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Now we can pull the animation
back in. Is it still here? It's not still here. We can always
pull the animation back in. >> Trust me. Now you're going
to insult and >> Oh, that's an insult. Well, you're telling
me that my >> Hey, uh, when you're in Discord, when you're
in >> So, how will you drop the other side when she stops?
I mean, like some of the things she's saying, I just have like
proof of those things. Like, obviously, when she says, um, what
do you call it? >> Oh, subox, thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you. Thank you. Oh, wait, no, that was gentle, wasn't it?
Gentle will, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go.
Um, no, I'll just wait. I'll wait for her to be punched out and
then I'll go post whatever I need to and it's all fine. you when
you're just sitting up staying up. I didn't ask you to stay up.
You stay up and talk to chat. Talk over me sometimes. >> And
I don't care. I'm cool with that. But you're not going to say
that that's me overworking you because I'm streaming and you
want to be in the frame.
>> no one made you stay up till 3. >> You drive until
we got home at 3:45, by the way. And nobody made, you know. Yes.
I volunteered to help you and drive and do all that. Yes, you're
right. And I got a couple hours sleep and then we got up at See,
you woke me up, knocked on the door at 7:30 and we got up and
we did a 2-hour drive back to Houston and then I No, let me speak
because Okay. It doesn't work. It's all right. I don't do that.
And I want you to >> What is that gonna happen when Desi
realizes this is a trap for him and Kelly isn't actually mad?
Uh, Kelly's mad. Wait, I'm I'm not surprised she's blowing up
on me. Cryptic command. I knew she was going to blow up on me.
She was like clearly very very very very hurt because I didn't
lose it on Cherry for Cherry like saying she felt weird that
Kelly was making multiple jokes on that stream,
right? that I that I didn't go and like ask tell Cherry that
you need to apologize immediately. It's like it's it's absurd.
>> Annoying it is. >> I want you to make the point
annoying it
>> We're better. >> I asked you at 7:30, "Are you
okay? I can make the trip on my own." >> And I made an
obligation and I'm a man of my work. >> Yeah. And then
you went into Discord and you're like, "Oh, I'm burnt out. I
can't do this." Like, no one asked you to. >> No, we can
bring the clips up if you'd >> What about the messages
in the Discord? >> Yes, that's what I'm saying. My message
that I was tired. I'm sorry, guys. I'm a little behind asking
people, hey, this is the scavenger hunt chat. Can we not have
a mile long thing, which God believed, but either way, in a private
scavenger hunt thing, there was just general conversation and
even I got into >> Do you understand how complaining about
being overworked? >> I wasn't complaining about being overworked.
I was complaining about not having sleep, Nick. I don't take
amphetamine. I don't take Adderall or
>> Uh, it did happen. Um, it's whatever. It It is what
it is. I didn't think it was like super intentional, super pointed,
but it was probably weird. And I just I didn't think like Cherry
being upset about it or annoyed about it was weird. >> or
methamphetamines or any of this to keep me going. You're right.
I was tired. I'm irritable. Yes, I'm like her right now. I'm
hungry, too. That's why I mentioned food. We were talking about
food while you were in there shopping for canes and stuff. Talked
about the pizza and stuff at the house and everything else. I
don't want to piss you off, dude. Because when you get picked
off, it's rapid fire, man. And honestly, it's just not cool.
I like you as a person when you are happy. But to make me feel
uncomfortable, get in a fight with your wife and then tell me
to stand there. >> Is it making me uncomfortable that you're
in this vehicle? Can No, you see, you don't give a about other
people's comfort levels. Just your own. >> Call the cops,
dude. >> Here we go again. >> Call the cops. Do it.
>> What is this? Here's one of the jokes. Like,
yeah, it's [__] up. I wish that I didn't. I wish
that I didn't. Okay, but I do. >> What we've learned is
just does in fact negotiate with terrorists. That was a lie.
I should have just threatened to kill myself. Then he wouldn't
have leaked my [__] >> Jesus Christ. I didn't
even know what to say. Like it was just a crazy thing to say
at that point. But yeah. So you were not dating her for a year.
>> That's what I learned. Will >> that is that is
kind of weird. Yeah. Kind of weird. But so I think Cherry was
just like annoyed about that and called Kelly out for that and
Kelly was like super and I was like I don't know. You guys should
solve that yourself. I don't know. It's weird. Oh, whatever.
>> They are doing the Angelica thing again. >> But
like
Yeah. I don't know. >> I'm just saying dude.
do this. >> You don't care about her wishes now, do you? You're
just going to keep saying it. Can you step out of my vehicle?
>> I just take
now. You're going to try and just leave me here. >> Well,
I offered to call you Uber back home. No, I offered to call your
Uber back home. >> Do you want the Uber? >> I would
like you to drive me back to the [__] place where
my car is. >> I don't feel comfortable with you in my >> Destiny's
ecstatic about this. >> Just like how you don't have to
explain >> me when I see Henry G in person from now
>> Now he's mad at Henry G. Remember a month ago he was
ready to look up the Henry G drama all over again. >> I'm
willing to Uber him. Uber. >> I'm going to Uber you. >> Very
transparent. Oh [__] >> Sorry. This is popping
off. We should go back. We should go back and actually watch
this. >> I don't feel comfortable with you in my >> I
don't have to explain that. Just like how you don't have to explain
why. >> What kind of [__] is that? >> Close
the door.
>> all right.
>> You don't care about her preference at all, do you?
As soon as you leave, I can drive off. >> Just Airbnb back
to the or Uber back to >> I'm willing to Uber him. I don't
have Uber or any of >> I'm going to Uber you. >> You
are literally in my car and I want you not in my car. I'm not
going right >> You brought me here, bro. >> And I'm
going to give you a ride home via Uber. >> Like I get it.
It's been a long day for everybody. A rolls got hit. Your [__]
didn't all this [__] happened. So I have your wallet's
gone. >> Just so I have it clearly. >> By the way,
you got a missing wallet. Anybody seen it? Where's the last place
Nick had it? >> Probably on the counter. >> There
we go. So you're freaking out on her over your wallet when you
think it's on the counter. We're not there. >> Can you
not understand that? Like finding it and seeing if it's in the
car is kind of important. >> Yes, I looked. I came out
here and looked for it when you asked me to. >> You asked
me and we both looked. >> The only dialogue I had was,
"Hey, can you look to see if you can find the me again?" Yes,
of course. You see, like, if you have such a great point, why
are you keep interrupting mine? >> The only thing I got
from her was, "It's too dark." Now, if you look for it, usually
people would say, "Oh, yeah, we looked at we don't think it's
here." Instead of, "It's too dark. It's too dark." And I asked
her, "Well, do you have a phone? A flashlight?" She goes, "Well,
yeah, I have a phone." >> I was like, "Then use it." And
I guess just jamming the music on the phone instead of caring
about the fact looking for it already before that and during
on the one I was >> there's an incredible amount of reticence
to [__] just use our body looks I might have missed
it. It's possible cuz all of it looks your wallet is dark and
slim and metal just like the center console. It looks very similar
to everything else in this car. >> In the future when you
lose something I'll look with that same figure. Okay. >> I
can't there's not multiple places I can look. I can't go upstairs
in the car to look. >> I can't like
it. >> Can you not see that if you message me and said,
"Hey, I looked around. I don't think it's anywhere." >> He
didn't ask me to until you bang on the door and yell at me. He
did not personally ask me to. You mentioned it. I looked in the
car that time. Are you >> Are you serious? >> So
if I show you the clip, you're good. >> No, I'm saying
before that. >> Hey chat, can you um can you pull the >> You
didn't come out to the car and ask me to look. You called me
and I told you I was looking. I already looked and I >> You're
going to get a big You're going to get a big benefit out of this
because one of the calls
>> it was muted. But the other call I'm curious what the
dialog said >> because I'm pretty sure I said, "Can you
look?" Can someone uh can someone throw >> Have they noticed
the chest yet? The chest got grabbed already. Tazo's got the
the chest.
>> Tazo got it. He walked away. >> I'm saying you
didn't come out >> You're right because I did. Yeah, >> you
went to open the door cuz you didn't see me. Allegedly, >> you
don't have to bang on it and yell at me cuz I already looked
for your stupid >> So, I'm just supposed to stand there
and indeed. Just this is so ridiculous. You're mad cuz you can't
find it and you blame me for not looking. I already looked. It's
not here. >> I cannot find something that isn't here. >> David,
are you refusing to get out of my >> Well, you want to
get ported now or
>> I do not feel comfortable with you in my feel comfortable
with you yelling at me to or telling me not yelling. Well, then
get out of the car. Don't be in the car with someone who's yelling
at you >> to get out of the car and stand there.
>> You can see the poles and stuff like that and do that
kind of thing. And here we go. Now you're going to go, "Oh, so
you can see?" Yes, N. We can see out the >> And it was
just too much for you to just say that. Yes. I mean, it's clear
to everyone that we can see out the window. >> Didn't want
the fighting. >> I really didn't. >> No one wants
the fighting. The point can you not understand that there's actually
a super important and practical reason why if someone's standing
literally breathing on the window, if they cannot be seen, >> we've
been here now for an hour >> and if you get out of the
car, we could leave without it. Literally >> try it. >> My
bad. Can you ask him to step out of the car? Do you want him
in the car? >> No, I thought you were getting him an Uber
back. >> Oh, no. I'd love to. He's not going to ride in
it. >> Can you please take the Uber? >> Can you step
out of the car? >> Get out of the car. >> Order the
Uber first so that way. Actually, you know what? Just do my thing
real quick. I get it because that's some [__] >> Do
you want the Uber or not? And where do you want me to send it?
All the way back to Houston, Florida. Where do you want? It >> depends.
What do you need? >> What do you mean what I need? >> What
do you need from me? >> You going to Uber him to Florida?
>> I don't understand the question. And because the agreements
and a lotment covers other side of not >> you just told
me that there's no documents and contracts. You said that. >> Yes.
And there's verbal that was inside of your home. So there's video
recording
>> I don't want to do that. And that's petty. Because I
don't play that financial game, dude. This is nonsense. >> So
you want me to let you stay another 60 days to finish out the
trial when it's already not going to work. >> Why isn't
it going to work? Because you made you yelled at your damn wife
and I just asked him not to do that, dude. >> And then
you let her yell at me and you don't give a [__]
>> Yes, I do, Nick. I'm not going to sit here and yell
at the woman too on the thousand people. You were screaming,
bro. She was crying. She's got It's not running down her nose.
Come on. Like, come on. >> I asked you to stand outside
the window. You stand as far as possible outside the window.
And then >> as far as possible would have been in that
door over there. >> You're right. As far as possible been
China in that direction. >> I'm right there. So >> my
point is you were on the edge of the curb. Like there's only
one parking spot here and you were standing with your >> In
the middle of parking lot in that >> That's not the middle.
That's literally the edge. >> That's where I was was in
the middle. >> you're saying that you were in the center
edge of the parking lot? >> Yeah. Like you can't really
get any further than the edge. >> Sure. So, where do you
want me to call the Uber? >> Wherever you would like to.
>> That's not how this works. >> My phone's about
to die. So, >> which is why I'm trying to call you an >> you
know what? If you're going to leave, I will give you a battery.
You can have it. You can take it back to Florida. >> How's
that? >> Great. I went live, too, so everybody
>> Okay. Um, can you get out of my car now, >> Yeah,
sure. Um, can I get that Uber? Make sure that I'm actually getting
it. >> so once again, the uh >> I wonder how he found
this guy. Did we learn about this from the start? I feel like
these were I feel like originally I thought these guys were also
kick streamers who were like coming with them >> this so
I can apply things >> and then what >> maybe by then
we can all calm down, chill out, do our thing and I'm hoping
that's the resolution we come to because I think this is nonsense.
>> That's not going to be the resolution. >> Okay,
cool. >> I started off asking you
said no. >> No you
I went over there I didn't do it right and then I said no because
I wasn't going to be spoken to that way and it gets you just
please finish it so I feel you. >> Well he doesn't give
a [__] now that he's going to be stubborn about it
because it's all about him. I'm already going to have night diapers.
I just want to go. Please.
>> Do you not understand that? Like >> is this is
this an escalation from the badger guy? Is this an escalation?
Did you start recording? >> I don't want to get in the
middle of it. That's fine. >> I said no and you continued
on. >> You did not say no. >> Yes, I did. >> You're
saying before you got out of the car, you said no. >> When
I got over there and you continued on and I said no. >> Does
she cry every stream? No. But I think what she's saying is she
got triggered. So Amaran's house was was burglarized, right?
She had three people break in and when loud bangs happen cuz
they banged on her door to try to get in, she starts crying.
She starts crying. So >> So what you're saying is where
she's at right now to stand outside the window. >> Neither
of them are stopping far across to the edge of the parking lot.
And then when I called out to you because you're far away. Now
I'm yelling.
>> Now I'm yelling. >> The edge of the parking lot.
>> I'm I'm very confused. Like >> it seems to be
an ongoing >> You said no, but you did it anyways. you
seem to be because one it kind of pain. So yes, I want to I want
to do the best I can but there's got to be a point where money
there's a certain point where I've got to look at it and go what
are my ethics worth? >> Your ethics of not seeing if we
can see outside this car >> of dealing with a husband that
is yelling at his wife
hands on the window which I did too. I apologize just because
it was recreating what was >> Can you see how the guy who
did it I don't want him in this vehicle. >> You did it
to that passenger window. >> Yeah, we're married. Um >> that's
okay when you do it. So, okay guys, just so you know, it's okay
if you're married to the woman to slam your hands on the window
and scare the [__] >> It is literally our car.
We both asked you to leave. >> No problem. Is the Uber
on its way or like I don't think that's on >> text me.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Text me. Is it uh Houston or is it wherever
else? >> I just told you. >> No, I'm going to give
you two Uber. >> Okay. I told you. Where? >> No.
Can you text me your address in
>> I've got to pick my car up, which is where? My car is
at your guys's house. >> You have the keys >> the
car. I need to go to the Airbnb and then I need to go to your
house so I can pick up my car. >> I mean I I can I can
route it to the house if you want as a second stop. >> Go
to the Airbnb. >> I know. Second stop. >> I'm letting
you know what I need. So what's the >> I'm saying is that
the is that the itinerary I'm trying to confirm with >> That's
what's being confirmed Nick like six times. >> Three. But
>> you that's literally the first time you said it. >> You
said you wanted to go from here to the Airbnb then to our house
and then like that's what you said. Is that what you're saying
you said six times? >> Yes. I said I wanted to go to Airbnb
because after all you're not driving me >> Jesus Christ.
Yes, we've established that. We've established you got to go
to the Airbnb. I'm saying the second leg of the Uber. Do they
not have Ubers in >> Where did I say I needed to go? I
have a car at your house. I know. So, I'm conf Uber home to Florida.
>> Can I I was confirming that. So, first leg Airbnb, second
leg to our house. Is that correct? >> It's a simple yes.
You didn't tell me six times. That original yes the first >> Yes,
Nick. >> That original yes was the first time.
>> That is that something Uber does? Like you is that regular
that you just go grab like a you go grab a
like an Uber and he'll take you like first your Airbnb and then
he'll just go and like take you from your Airbnb all the way
to Houston like hours away. >> Guess was the first time.
Yes. >> No. See, you don't give a [__] She
says neither do you. You're still >> Do they just get paid
insanely for like long trips like that? Is that why they do it?
They're just like, "Yeah, whatever. I get like I'm just going
to make insane money here." >> Continuing. I'm just sitting
here trying to end this and get a Uber back to a Airbnb. If any
other streamers are watching this, can y'all come take me to
the Airbnb?
If anybody is in this watching this, this is ridiculous. Pull
up at the Walgreens where uh the just just were. >> You
know, you have a phone that can >> Hell, my phone's dead.
>> That's why I asked you for a battery pack, dick. >> Weren't
you paying attention? >> No, we bought them if we left
them because there was a black pack.
>> This one's at
that one's empty. >> Well, no. I check. >> Okay.
How much do you want about? >> I don't care. And this I
don't have
to either come on here. >> What is uh >> apparently
Destiny is on food shop stream right now. Um very cool that in
the hour where he is crashing out about the about Rose's age
in DG chat. Okay. He goes to hang out with somebody else who
enjoys the company of miners. That's a very interesting decision
on his part,
I would say. Do you think he's aware that this person's a or
do you think do you think he's aware or
>> what is the plan in terms of later today tomorrow? Are
you wanting to go get food or what's going on? >> I just
want to go to the Airbnb. Why does this matter? >> Well,
because
I'm probably not going to
>> Because I don't know. I don't know. Maybe you just like
getting [__] over again and again and again and again.
But like the last time we trusted someone >> I have no
idea who you're talking about, man. I should go watch some of
the Aiden stuff of this person getting exposed for messaging
another minor. I think I didn't I don't know. I didn't watch
the whole thing >> to go. >> I just fig I'd let you
guys know just in >> A [__] ton of files and
so this is going to be an entirely ownorous trip where we're
going to have or at least I will have to go back and escort him
through the premise. >> For what? You have cameras everywhere.
I'm not going to stop. >> Yeah, I have cameras for Jacob,
too. And I got a bunch of videos of him deleting >> I'm
not What the [__] do I have to delete? I've been
here two weeks, dude. If you want, I have to voice you when I
get there. >> That doesn't do anything. >> Okay.
I'm just like cameras everywhere recognition. I understand. >> I
feel comfortable with that. >> I just want my car. >> [__]
I know. That's what I'm saying. >> Either way, you've got
to go back there. So, why are we doing this? And why don't we
just make a good old >> will murder you if you prioritize
Aiden's food shops coverage over this over his No, Aiden just
did a stream like the other day, like two days ago. Like I think
Aiden's last stream was he was covering food shop stuff where
they were like more I think it was more DMs with minors, but
I'm not really sure. >> On about trip. >> I'm just
saying because now you're saying you've got to go back there
any >> cuz I don't want the ride with you for >> dude.
I'll say I won't say. No, I don't like you behind me in a chair.
>> You want me in the like trunk? >> No, I'm going
to call you. >> I'm going to leave my handgun here for
you so that way there's no tension, no trouble. I'm not trying
to be honest. >> I'm not I'm not going to >> What's
making you uncomfortable? >> I don't have to define that.
>> Okay. So, nothing. And it's just being uncomfortable,
which is okay. It's acceptable. It's completely reasonable. >> I'm
asking because Oh, Jesus. Okay. Well, I guess we're not going
to mute anything, but like um if I go back to make sure nothing
happens, you're going to stay here. Go back. What's the plan?
Cuz I don't feel like you should be driving that distance tonight,
but I would have to drive that distance tonight. And so then
it would be the crazy thing of like what you're gonna ride down
and up with me or be there kind of logistical nightmare here.
>> Sure. So I don't know what some Why don't you just you
can stay at the Airbnb tonight? >> I don't want him under
the same roof as much as I can. >> Okay. Well, I just don't
want people driving tired. >> He's going to be riding a
>> Sure. But then if you're if you >> I'm No, I'm
fine. I am fine. I'm fine. >> I'm fine. >> Okay.
What is this? >> I'm extending my hand. >> For what?
>> To shake your damn hand. >> For what?
>> This This is weird and confusing to her and me. What
are you doing? >> Let's go shaking your hands. We can let
bygones be bygones and just move >> I don't think you understand
how this >> This is weird now. >> Oh, you better
try me again. >> This is just weird to try to shake his
>> to replicate you standing outside exactly the way you
were standing >> Your trust by saying no. >> No,
no. It's I asked you, can you stand outside like earlier and
you stood way further than we were earlier? >> That's okay.
I'm sorry. I [__] up. >> No. Well, I opened
the window said, "Can you come closer?" And then you went >> I
didn't hear that. All I hear is you yelling at me, bro. >> Wait,
wait, wait. Say that again. You said you didn't hear it, but
you heard me yelling. Now, now do you understand? Now do you
understand? Now do you understand? Now do you understand? Now
do you understand? Now, do you understand why I raised my voice?
Because you were far away. Because you couldn't hear me. Thank
you. Thank you. What I'm saying? I can't process. Thank you for
condemning your own. They won't >> You couldn't hear me.
So, I raised my >> Made the wrong word. Said the wrong
words. I'm tired. You're tired, too. >> I'm fine. >> Great.
Your eyes. >> You're exhausted. >> No, I'm perfectly
fine. >> Your eyes are bloodshot to hell. They're >> eyes
are always bloodshot. >> There's bags under them. You're
exhausted. We're all exhausted. We're all exhausted. >> And
you're making this take longer. >> Yep. Because I'm waiting
for all of us to go back to the Airbnb drive either way. There's
0% of that happening. >> Like, damn. >> there's 0%
of that happening. >> Oh, nothing. >> You could be
You could drive home with >> No, I don't want him in the
car behind me at any point. >> I'm I'm talking to people
on Discord. I'm I'm literally just laughing at like um what I
think Destiny just posted this and he's like, "Look, guys, I
totally thought she was like of age. We know that she represented
herself as 19 to you. That wasn't the point. It was the the point
was that you didn't do any due diligence for all of the sussy
[__] you were hearing, right? We've made that point
again and again that you you knew she was 19 or sorry, you you
knew that she said she was 19,
right? But she didn't have Only Fans. She didn't have a platform
that was age verified. She had braces. Her parents wouldn't let
her come visit you, right? There's a whole bunch of things.
Just post his DMs. I have to go find them. I have a I have like
a log that >> your ice cream across the >> I I have
like the HTML logs. Whoops, wrong video. I have the HTML logs.
>> Why you go? I can go show them. If he wants to say if
he wants to say that he didn't tell me that he was like, "Oh,
I didn't actually I don't think I actually checked her age."
And that's the only thing that would get me if she if she was
actually a minor, I would be if she if he wants to deny that
he told me that, he can do so. That'd be totally
>> He's not in the city. >> I know, but >> are
you kidding me? >> Houston, I mean, we could meet him at
home, but if you're scared about like someone you need someone
to be >> Are you Stop stop. He doesn't live close to us
either. It's like 45 to an hour for him. You want him to do that
in the dev night? Please, please, please. You're showing you're
showing how out of touch you are. >> Why? Because it takes
like two and a half hours to drive home. By this time, it's morning
time. >> I don't think you can commit 4 a.m. >> Do
you understand that it is not really fair to commit him to doing
that for
>> Does that make sense? >> I'm just trying to present
alternatives
cuz I don't because you don't seem like you have a solution.
>> No, my solution is to figure out what My solution is
to figure out what you want and then try to triangulate between
that and what I need to do. >> I want to go home tomorrow.
Ideally, tonight I'm too tired. >> Oh, no. You're not going
to be >> Well, I need my car. So if you take me home in
my car cuz we I don't know how to drive the rolls then how are
you going to get back you drive a different car to landing. >> So
rolls a standard or >> what do you >> must be I guess
>> like if you wanted to bring the lambos and to Austin
where a bunch of hills. >> Well duh I guess stop stop.
If that was the way it'd be crazy and dumb and then basically
I'd have to Uber back here. So my question to you is would it
not just be easier to stay a bit in Austin? You
>> I just remember Russell will come on Sunday so we can
bring you back. You don't have to pick you up. Okay. So, we Uber
him back to the Airbnb. We Uber him back to the home, >> We
drive to that,
>> this is going to go on.
>> Well, not cuz it's going on social media. Oh, my bad.
>> Hey, what's up? >> Oh, hello. >> Yo, hey,
what's up? Yeah, yeah, yeah, I >> Destiny currently pretending
like he wasn't watching you and Auggie to food shops even though
he was literally in your chat.
Cool. >> Yeah, Airbnb. Yeah, sure. You're saying Uber.
Okay. It's like it is just funny because he's been here what,
three or four times this month typing the chat? Three or four
times, I think. >> I mean, that that is that is definitely
a solution. Um >> Oh, he's very late at night. >> Well,
okay. So, I think after she calms down, it just makes more sense
for us to be relatively in the same place. >> Who's on
the phone? I'm sure he'll post the evidence right away.
Okay. I Dude, K, stop. If you're going to talk about it, just
go talk about it in the Discord or talk about it somewhere else.
All right. You can talk about it in the Discord. Go ahead. Keep
it out of the chat for now. We'll watch it tomorrow. >> Yeah.
Yeah.
Right. Yeah. Something else to obscure you but not blot out the
ability for the windows to be windows. >> Can you turn
that away? >> Can you get out of my [__] car?
>> I can't film you in my car. >> I was asking not
to film. >> No, I asked you to get out of the car. You
wouldn't want to get out of the car. Now you want to do something.
>> Now that Kelly is gone, is Spinboy coming back? Maybe.
>> Well, you can wait for it outside of my car. What? >> Probably
not. >> You can wait outside my car.
This is the uh this is the last image spin boy posted in the
Discord by the >> Hold on. >> What are you talking
about? Well, yeah, >> this is the last image that Spinboy
posted in the Discord. >> Now it doesn't matter apparently
because you don't want to be on the phone. >> Oh, hold
on. Is this a gift? >> Oh, it is a gift. Hold on. >> You
literally made a point about food, >> And so I said, "Fine,
>> this is the last picture that Spinboy posted. His last
logs." >> Don't white knight.
>> You think this is white knighting? It's >> trying
to spin the entire situation. >> Let me give you a quick
uh little lesson here. Okay. When you work for a company, I >> you
work for it. That's fine. Are you done yet, buddy? Get the [__]
out of my >> Okay. If you're going to stay, you're going to
[__] listen.
>> Yes. Or don't stay. It's your own valition, man. This
is my property. >> Yep. Absolutely. Actually, it's Kate's
>> Oh my god.
>> Uh, no. It's Kate's, actually. >> I think that's
just going to escalate, but I mean, I'll say that. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, it'll stop me from downloading it yourself. Oh,
no. He was saying he's trying to download Uber. Oh, no. My bad.
Yeah. Yeah. The the war thing. Sure. Sure. >> I'll let
Russell know I do have a couple things of his that need to be
returned to him as well. >> He's saying that he has some
of your stuff that he needs to return. I mean, I feel like that's
a Yeah, I don't think there's a problem with that >> No,
he's saying he has some of your stuff that he needs to return
to you. What do you have of his stuff? >> I have stuff
from the upstairs lounge. >> Wait, wait, wait. What? >> Stuff
from the upstairs lounge that he had brought >> smoking
stuff? Yeah. >> Why do you have that?
>> I'm almost, by the way, I'm almost positive that Kelly
repeatedly asked me to have Spinboy banned.
It's weird that she's like, "Oh,
I guess I guess this is why Spinboy." Kelly repeatedly was like,
"I will not rejoin your Discord until the Pickle and Spin Boy
are banned." That was her line in the sand like constantly. I'm
pretty sure I didn't ban them. Like Like I just kind of was like,
"That's weird." And she did rejoin eventually. I'm pretty sure
Kelly and Spinboy were at the same were there at the same time.
>> I guess I'm not mistaken. >> Uh brought along
the uh remnant of what you guys had put up there. Um basically
because you had said that I could have
No, absolutely. I didn't bring I didn't No, no, no, no. I didn't
bring the whole the whole CR No, I didn't bring like every Yeah.
No, that's not me.
>> Yeah, there's a a bunch of crosswires and I apologize
on that. >> So, do you have anything that needs to be returned?
>> Yes, I can drop off at the house when I go pick up my
car. That's not an issue. I was just letting him know. >> You
brought what the whole supply of one of those things or what?
>> One of what things? >> Oh my god. >> I'm
asking you. >> I literally Okay. Yeah, guys. Obviously,
it's crazy to further isolate somebody who feels isolated, whose
chief complaint about about not feeling well is feeling isolated
from people. It's crazy to further isolate them. That's like
obvious, right? To say, "Oh, no. Don't hang out here. Don't hang
out any of the places you normally do. You've got to leave. You
got to go." I just feel like that's it's just obvious. But maybe
I don't know. Whatever. >> Don't understand what any of
that stuff >> Okay. Well, if you can't describe it, I don't
know. What did you grab from the >> Uh, don't worry. When
we're off stream, we can talk about that. It's nothing illegal.
Everything >> now. It's about off stream. >> Well,
no. You've got yours unmuted now. >> It's always been unmuted.
>> Her business is >> I don't care whether it's unmuted.
>> What are you talking about? >> The whole time
her stream's been not >> cool. I'm just letting you know.
>> What's What's your point? >> Yeah, I don't care
if it's muted. >> You want me to mute her stream or what?
>> But anyways, what's the plan here? Um, >> that's
up to me. >> I'm trying to figure it out, too. >> Anything
from here. So >> I think that What did you No, Hold on.
Hold on. What did you bring? It doesn't matter though, Nick.
>> You brought drugs. >> No stuff that you can buy
in a smoke shop, dude.
>> That's not bringing drugs. >> Why'd you bring
all of it? >> I didn't. >> So, what did you bring
then, >> Nick?
Besides the [__] >> David, just say what you
want. >> Yeah, just what you brought. >> Take care.
>> This is getting weird. >> I brought your Coke,
Nick, >> that's not all right. >> I don't use Coke.
>> Stop that. >> You have Coke. >> No, I don't.
>> Then what did you bring? >> You're not going to
[__] kid. >> You just on live stream said you
have my Coke. I don't have any Coke. So, whose Coke do you have?
>> I don't have any Coke. And why did you say that? >> Because
you want a knee-jerk reaction, >> David. All I wanted was
what you >> Correct. And I provided that to you. >> It's
his stuff. Can you not ask you? >> I asked you what you
brought. I was just wondering what you want from that. >> The
I'm fine with it being on stream. That's fine. >> I don't
care. >> So mod the >> How much of it? >> How
much of what the mod is? >> The mod is an electronic thing.
>> Oh, it's a vape thing. >> Yeah. Yeah, it's a vape
thing. It's not It's not >> Is it the metal one or the
pink one? >> No, it's it's it's the blue one. >> It's
like a Yeah, it's a blue one. What else did you grab? >> I
didn't grab the blue one. The one I brought with us was the two
or the the shark one or whatever the hell that is. >> Yeah,
I brought that one. >> And I got some uh
>> you're the one who cough with that man. >> You
want to buy a drug test right now and I can we can both on stream.
>> Whether you have or you're using it >> buy a drug
test for both of us right
>> The car. >> No, I'm not going with you. >> You
want to take a test? We'll both take >> Why would I take
one? >> Don't try me on this [__] >> Are
you serious? Anyways, >> I just want to know what else
did you >> The two tubes you had >> the gold tubes.
>> Yeah, the gold tubes because uh that was going to be
for AC7 when we went and hung out with >> I mean this is
this is what we've been >> is we think it's we think this
is what it is >> things that aren't yours.
>> I was told that we could split things. Nick,
it was literally talked about. I'm sorry you weren't involved
in the conversation, but that's what happened.
>> Emaranth is chilling, I guess. I have no [__]
idea. >> Still there. I didn't steal or do anything like
that. So everything's still accounted for. >> Dude, you
have a problem with what? >> When you tell him that you
have a gift for him, it it seems like you're giving him something,
but you're Indian giving something that someone else said you
could use some of.
>> It's really weird.
>> that's rude. >> I would prefer it. I mean, they're
not going to be going forward, but I would prefer that you cleared
with me. Oh, I'm sorry. None of this is you. If you're going
to bring >> anything me having a medicinal marijuana license,
I need to clear that with you. >> That's David. You can't
use that index >> I'm from Florida. >> You're in
the state, buddy. >> Okay. Well, here's the thing. It was
sold over the counter and I have a receipt for >> So, you
bought this? >> For what? Wait, what? >> Okay. Now,
we've got new things. I I'm honest. I will literally have what
the I say I have, and it will all be accounted for by Red. >> So,
what else do you have? >> Don't worry about it. >> Oh
my god. >> I have nothing of yours yet. >> How much
did you bring? You're on a work trip. You go. >> Who's
smoking? >> Well, then why'd you bring it? >> Really?
Are you serious? >> On a work trip when you went out the
Boston to visit him before and hang out. >> Yeah, on stream.
>> And you ripped a 4ft bong. No problem. >> On stream,
correct? In front of like 7,000 people. What do you What's the
secret here? I would like to know. With just a couple thousand
people. What the You take or bring? >> I didn't steal anything.
>> I didn't say that. >> I didn't take anything.
I brought stuff with us.
>> That's not illegal in any sense of the [__]
word. >> Yeah. Yeah. Neither was the thing that they ripped
because they bought it at the store that was literally >> Okay,
cool. >> in Austin. He was on stream as well. >> I
don't like You're trying to insinuate.
>> Don't mind. >> Yeah. What else did you bring?
>> What did you bring, Nick? >> Uh, a couple cigars
for the two of us >> And what else? >> That's it.
>> Where you go in the vlog? >> Uh, there's ice cream
in the back, but it's probably really [__]
>> Hold on. Hold on. If you're going to If you're going
to go, then I guess I'll go with you. But >> what do you
need?
>> You check if the I'm sure. So, I got you an entire gallon.
I'm sure some of it's so good. If you Is there a spoon here?
You're going to need a spoon to eat it. I mean,
>> yeah, sure.
>> Yeah. I don't like the uh >> I don't know. >> I
feel like should she have the ice cream literally here? And I
would rather not leave anyone alone with anyone. >> I mean,
>> well, that and also just uh the the off chance that
he gets the Airbnb before I do, right? >> What the [__]
What do you have here? That's that important. First of all, I'm
not going to [__] deal or do anything >> You're
already [__] suing Jacob and all this other [__]
Why do I want to be >> You couldn't even just calmly explain.
>> Don't even go there with me. >> Hey, how about
this solution, Kaitlin?
If if she went back to the Uber, she could lock the door, not
let anybody in until you were there. >> Let me ask you
something. Do you have a criminal history? I do a background
>> Um, apparently Destiny took credit for doxing Riyle,
which is weird cuz the account that doxed Riyle also docked some
other people. So, it's kind of weird that Destiny's taking credit
for these things. I don't know. I
>> no. I'm sorry. Not you. >> No, yours.
>> Mine? What? What? What? >> No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. This ombre. No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. >> So, you do have one. >> No, actually don't.
>> So, if I run a background check, >> you're not
going to pop up. >> I'm just saying that's a weird thing
to >> I mean, I work for, you know, >> Good one.
Good one, Ogre boy. >> Why aren't you working for a government
>> Cuz I left it during >> You left it or they fired
you? >> I went back to school.
>> I know. 12.99 was not good. benefits. >> Anyways,
yeah, Red, I think the plan is um I'll call him an Uber, actually.
>> Yeah, but he's driving away.
>> Okay, we're almost at the end of this. I might skip
into their VOD cuz apparently apparently them driving back to
Houston is really good. Dombre based on the other people that
that account doxed. I don't I did not think it was him. No. Very
bizarre. Very bizarre stuff, dude. This guy with the costumes.
I guess it'll be in the doc disrespect vod, >> Who'd come
in and say But like he goes, >> it hasn't."
>> This be where they start fighting >> or I have
perfect
spherical big solid
Reason anyone. >> What the [__] >> So
he's back at the Airbnb here, but I thought they drove Did they
not drive back to uh Houston? Looks like he drives back to Houston.
Does he drive back by himself? No way. >> Lined up this
week after his >> Does he just drive back to Houston by
himself? just going. Wait, Vegas?
There's no way he goes to Vegas.
What? I don't know why you guys are saying. >> I want to
take a break. >> I'm lost. Sorry. >> It's pretty
grueling schedule from what I've seen. Anyways, >> Badger
took an Uber on this, >> but he's here and I think he drives
back to Houston by himself.
Like, he literally drives for hours. The sun comes up and then
he gets back to his house. Yeah. So, he's back at his house.
Does he really go back to his house, dude? What? Dude, no wonder
he was definitely on like some aderall or something. What the
[__] So, they drive they drive all the way to
Austin in the Airbnb. They're cooking. Then they're outside for
a little bit. They get in a fight. He drives all the way back.
He's in his house. He watches his own VOD.
Copes to his chat in his room. Hold on. Can you guys see me scanning
through this? Like drives all the way back. He's back in his
own house. Okay. Watches his own VOD in his house. watches Ice
watch his VOD in his house. Continues to rant. Continues to rant.
Continues to rant. I don't see anywhere where he's gone to sleep.
He gets back in the car.
He drives, drives, drives, drives.
He's driving. He's driving. Dude, what the goes out. He's back
at the This is the Airbnb with his pigeon. And then he's at the
Airbnb with Amaranth. And then he goes to H. No. Amaranth goes
to sleep and he's walking around with crutches. Bro, >> this
thing >> he goes hard. Someone told me that his his trip
back though, >> driving back is good, >> but I can't
see it being good if he's by >> Like the very first day
you came on, we had a conversation where I said, and I thought
I was being very clear. I said, listen,
the problem previously is that working relationships with merge
with friendships, and that's just not a good
we can be friendly. We can hang out, right? Cuz like especially
if you're like going to be hanging out while I'm streaming
like like for instance last night I don't mind
like I I will
sometimes when you're like jumping in and and like talking a
bunch it's like okay whatever. >> Let me see what else
we got on the >> I'm going to let him go for a second.
some of the people in chat
like hey guys come on right you want to be a part of the conversations
>> maybe a little I could go back and do a little more
of the fente stuff too we'll see watching give me a second >> but
don't in any way insinuate that I made you stay up and work that
I'm more than happy to talk to my chat myself there is no pressure
for you to stay up and I've never given that to you in fact I
ask you you tired uh you know turn in no it's not that I I mean,
I think going forward, we might just have people who are strictly
singular roles, right? Security or camera person, right? Or admin.
We're not going to do merging. It It's going to suck because
we'll probably find someone with like all the skill sets in one
person, but the separation is just a formality that needs to
be observed. The far about No.
Okay, I'm back.
>> You got anything without a Nick? No, I got nothing without
a neck. How long does it take him to come back and doesn't realize
it? Don't just screw me. Shut up. >> Interpretive liberty
in that way. Orders are spoken. Non-spoken
is not an order. Literally an even worse understanding than Jacob.
Jacob at least was like, "Do you want this? I can line up a divorce
attorney." Blah blah blah blah. Right. Jacob didn't say, "Because
you have not said you don't want one, I will get you a divorce
attorney." No, no, no. He asked her, "Do you want this or not?"
Right. I still think that's kind of instigating
cuz like >> why is Citrus watching? Citrus is in Nick's
chat. >> If they want it, they can do it. Like Like why
are you making it super easy and lined up? Also, I want an explanation
for why I want an explanation for why you took the Jeep up when
I asked you to clear it with Kate first. That wasn't an option.
Does anybody know who he's talking to?
Like, I'm sorry, but I actually don't know who he's talking to
right now. >> That wasn't a option. You don't get to come
to me and say yep when she didn't [__] tell you yes
because you didn't ask for someone who worked for both of us.
It's kind of weird that you didn't ask either of us when it suits
you. Also, David, do you remember a conversation we had? I want
to touch on this because I'm not trying to be a hard ass. I don't
think or care if anyone does weed. It's fine. If you're an adult,
you want to do that. Yay. If it helped you relax, great. But
David, I want to cite something
that I was trying to say, but I and I think you knew I was trying
to say it, hence why you kept interrupting me. Do you remember
a conversation we had
where I said, "Listen, on work trip, on work trips, meaning when
you are going with us on a trip for work, there will be no drinking,
no drug use.
You need to be >> Can I send a quick clip for you? It sounds
ultra weird. Uh
>> sure. Send the clip. >> Crystal clear of sound
mind. And you >> wait, hold on. Wait. Describe it for me.
Neosc describe it for me first cuz depending on what this is,
I'm not going to watch it. But just describe it. Whatever it
is, people click the clip. Describe the clip. I'll check it out.
But I I do not want to I just I want to be careful cuz obviously
he's probably sending food shops sealed transcript
>> Okay. You know, >> don't show this. This is what
I'm talking about. Do you understand?
>> Yeah, I know. Okay. So, okay. No, it's >> No,
but the whole thing is like this. The whole thing is like it's
so wacky.
>> I was so irritated when they moved to seal this and
I'm like Yeah, but I'm like there's no no duh to seal it. But
it's like that's interesting.
Um, cool. I don't know. Is that allowed? Are you allowed to do
that? I don't know if you're allowed to do that or something.
Huh. Just
people engaging in their true passions. Okay. One minor attracted
person meets another minor attracted person and they just have
great times together. It is what it is. >> Said, "Of course."
And I told you occasionally I will.
>> Oh, Stumps. Well, sorry, Stumps. If you're not familiar,
there's um there was a transcript from a hearing, a preliminary
injunction hearing that Destiny had that they sealed in the Pixie
case. And apparently it's sections from that.
Yeah. So that's why he says, "Oh, it's so weird that they tried
to seal it." So is he like trying to weaponize food shops while
play? Yeah. Food Chops community is like the pro Destiny hub
on YouTube now. I think it's weird that they are reaching out
to like an actual I I just figure like your optics I thought
his optics were healing but apparently
>> do a bong hit because everyone wants to see that for
some reason. I'm doing it for the content.
You won't ever see me doing it not on
>> It will never happen. It's not something I normally
would do of my own valition, right? But I will if they want to
see it and I find it to be mostly harmless anyways. It's no different
than if someone linked me a video and I was like, I wouldn't
have watched it on my own, but if you all want me to watch it,
let's let's go. I told you trips.
No substant. You didn't go well.
Can I bring someone else's? I have a [__] out of
state. >> Oh, right. Holy x grail. That is a fantastic
point. That is an actually fantastic point.
>> Medicinal waiver, bro. I said no substances. If you
have an issue, talk to me. I couldn't be more clear.
That's why I'm like, "Wait, look, it's bringing to you bring
because why would you bring >> if you're not supposed to
be using it? Come on." >> Guess they may have actually
shared sealed documents with food shops just then. I don't know.
Is he not allowed to do that? I don't know if he's allowed to
do that or not. Maybe he just shared Zip Zip's notes or something.
>> New splash. Since you care so much about what Kate feels,
she doesn't like me using we at the house nor any of those things.
That's mostly a her rule that I'm communicating. >> Money
Morgan, go back in the vibe. There's just uh there's some magic
moments earlier in the vi came by uh to just kind of check and
make sure everything was okay. Um
I briefly met Shuvi cuz they're trying to get the chest. That
was it for tonight that I recognized. Everyone was pretty orderly.
No one did anything crazy to us at least. Yeah, Juvie was like
I would say Badger, you want to stand there and dispute what
I just said cuz I don't think you'll do it. We had this conversation
about no substances
on work trip. Is that right? >> Is he pretending that this
was about Badger being on weed or >> when you asked me
what's the problem with me doing this? Well, if we had a prior
conversation and you agreed, that's my problem. >> I mean,
I assume the Coke was for Nick. I assume that's the reason we're
going 20 29
hour no sorry
34 hours a 34 hour stream where he sleeps for none of it I assume
that's what gets us through that is consistent coke usage right
I mean realistically it's empetamine abuse I guess that would
get you further through but what do you mean I'm confused I have
not blocked anyone I don't I think the only person in the history
of the universe that I've ever banned is ban collector one guy
I don't care If you use it on the weekends when you're not at
work, when you're at home, I don't feel like I exert that kind
of control on your life. You can do it. In fact, I'm not even
going to be like on a regular day at work, you know, maybe you
you took something before you came in or whatever. If you can
function and you're not sitting there blitzed and saying, "Oh,
what do I do? How do I open this bag?" If you're not doing that,
I'm okay with it. Right? It's pretty lack. Our workplace is very
lax.
But I did specifically ask you. I specifically asked you. You
understand that when we're on trips, I don't want any substitutes.
And you said, "Understood. If you had an issue, that would be
the moment to say, well, I have this thing.
Here's my doctor's notice."
You feel that way. Don't tell me yes. Of course, though. I'm
not going to tell you that I'm going to do the opposite. >> Dude,
hold on. Just look at this. >> There's a reason I asked
for that. Is this him ranting like as the sun comes up? >> I
needed to know. >> Oh, hold on.
>> Like literally the sun starts coming up. >> You're
going to be functional.
>> It's just him like yell ranting for an hour as the sun
comes up. >> But going back to my story and then >> out
for a second, comes back. >> But you don't confer with
them. You don't ask them. Take the silence of mean whatever you
want it to mean. It's not it's not a tinable situation because
that's unmanageable, right? It's literally the on steroids form
of ask dad, ask mom, right? >> Wishes he had this energy.
I kind of do. This energy is super impressive. >> I asked
dad, he said no, but mom didn't say no yet, but I didn't ask
her. So that's yes. Like how the am I ever supposed to get anything
done? Now I'm not saying it was abused to that extent, but like
it opened the door for the same thing. I'm not going to fall
asleep. I'm wide awake. I haven't even popped open the [__]
yet. Dude, you know what? As a precaution, your cheers for your
consideration must airing like speed, violence, and momentum.
Now, like I'm I'm going to open it up for you guys comment in
just a second. But like here's the thing, right? I think going
forward, here's the governing principle. If I give you an order,
you do it. Tell me why I'm wrong or it cannot done. Okay? Or
you can resign. That's it. That change. That's how it works.
You do it or you tell me why it can't be done, why I'm just plain
wrong. Or you can resign because the whole, "Okay, I'll say it's
fine. It's good. We'll do it that way." And then later come back
and saying, "Well, that's ridiculous." It's like, "Dude, let's
talk about this already." The time to bring it up was way earlier.
It really left a bad flavor in my mouth, but I thought I was
going to have a private conversation with him later. Like I don't
like him going into Discord and kind of like in my opinion it
was vinting and he made it sound like he was burnt out because
he was assigned too much. He didn't which he should have said
anything but like he didn't fight that well. I chose to hang
out with my boss until the we hours of morning and then I wouldn't
watch my other boss. >> Oh whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Oh no.
Neck. No.
Um hold on. I might go. Guys, if you want to join the Discord,
we could go watch the uh the food shop stream. I'll peace out
and I might go watch that. I was probably going to listen to
it anyway just to see exactly what he's saying, but I'll probably
go hang out in the Discord. If you guys want to join the Discord,
All right. You can go join up. You can stream this if people
are watching. If not, I mean, I'm just going to go hang out,
watch, and see what's up. Yeah. Okay. All right. W stream. W
stream, guys. 20 seconds left. Have a good night, everybody.
Okay. Have a good night. Thank you everybody for being here tonight.
And we'll be back tomorrow.
Have a good one. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.